salut twitch bassa l'ufab c'est lui qui
a tous je serai en forme pour un beau
match de ce pitch est alors attend enfin
que je regarde si les gens de les voir
de la mer vais sur l'écran je regarde
des joueurs très beau match un beau
match c'est une belle c'est une belle
scène de la chicha fab ce soir ouais
avec mes joueurs pas comprenait pas trop
donc c'est un côté 51 fléchissant quoi
d'après mme wafa je pense que zen et
quand même gros favoris du match aller
ouais je conseille aux visites sur wii
mais bon est ce que vit dit ah non mais
ce que est ce que vit dit à artaq chez
meetic annoncé si tu attaques un jardin
km au dessus de tout quoi ouais c'est
vrai que le côté attaque peut faire pour
se pencher le match je sais pas mais en
plus vous en était déjà à fond quand on
a fait la fraude chez sig avec artaq je
pense que là on est obligé de l'examen
est quoi fondre battue je pense pas
qu'on ait le choix quoi bon alors à
tomber
bon vote pour vous dit peut-être le
petit jeunot quoi enfin peux tu peux tu
te placer face à hart ac 1
je sais pas quoi et eu le courage de le
placer face à heart attack by tu fais ce
que tu veux tu vas faire moi même avait
quand même impressionné le petit artaq a
pour nom la proue de châssis pour
accrocher ce livre après non sur les
phases finales - finale où moi je leur
joue et tu vois on est parties en blitz
comme ça n'ont pas beaucoup de médailles
d'or ray mais moi je les jouais je les
jouais quand moi j'ai joué sur les
arénas le petit le petit artaq ne m'a
pas impressionné non plus mais bon tu te
dis
quand je suis en train de remettre le
bâti de femmes vas-y des maîtres bons
titres 8
donc ces visites contre ces andriatiana
ou à adria cciab andriatiana en dérision
y avait garé sa réponse suffit des
points communs avec harry c'est pas un
bon jeu sur leur bailleur m et lui aussi
il écrit avec un lycée ils ont niveau on
ne savait pas ce que ses fans lui sur
facebook a même été créé avec un guidon
du coup plus personne ne savait comment
s'écrit son nom du coup ils lui ont
demandé les coiffes calais va agir tout
recommencer gré et non ccc y bon ils ont
dit ok on y fait un copieux et varié on
y verra si tu veux quoi déroulé ce que
nous on peut faire gagner une ibiza ski
avec sa méthode w sinon là aujourd'hui
plutôt enlevée et art of non mais moi
comme j'écris qu'un w comme mon frère
était dans la merde
ben tu vas y à la fin tu m'as y j'ai
visité avec un y
juste une question l'adresse c'est bien
twitch pour un tv slhs com fr ouais
c'est bien ça mais j'ai lu j'ai lu un
commentaire sur un chat emmené ici n'ont
surtout pas bor'de'lo commentaire oh
mais moi je me suis pas trop vexé parce
que ce qu'il avait mis à y à la fin du
nom précis avec ne sait même pas écrire
mon nom ma tête c'était pas toi mr louis
ou peut-être c'était un autre nom mais
je dis tu as de basket doit pas trop
regarder tu as le make up
si déjà il sait pas écrire ton nom tu
sens pas le mec qui avouent regarder
deux contenus tu vois dans l'est ce que
ça a commencé cette histoire ce mois je
suis censé suivre vie dit mais je crois
pas encore bon écoute je sais pas ce qui
se passe a commencé à clémentine il va
voir les noirs dans le prêt à porter et
la pause le savez ne pensait de tourner
donc le rail loach comme écoute il
similaire à 28,87 vingt dix 90 du coût
avantageux visite
l'info en plus que toi at-elle
donc avis aux quatre drames intimes et 2
2 b 6 on avait préparé un truc pour le
répertoire facile tu te rappelles ouais
mais bien manger prépare un autre truc
pour le répertoire facile va rentrer des
changes beaucoup plus simple ouais mais
bon
non il en prenant répertoire faskil où
va-t-on faire ça plutôt master class 1
était devra faire un répertoire très
facile du coup une vidéo 15 minutes pour
une ouverture fois plus j'ai appris à la
rigueur un truc vraiment très facile un
répertoire très facile en fait du coup
donc c'est parti pour ce match
fab et les savanes ont pour visite
l'ouverture s'est bien passé quand même
ouais non mais ok juste va jouer on a
une structure un peu plus de françaises
bon je t'aime tu resteras chang'e 3 et
donc vous les blancs ont la caisse des
4/10 marquise moines y installer une
pièce un jour bon les noirs eux ils vont
faire pression sur re5 nous ça va être
dur de faire petit raconte n'a
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs ces mondiaux repart de
l'autre côté reste à être beaucoup plus
dur que ça n'y était au coude avant fin
mars à arles et blanc aussi
non on est bien il peut faire parce que
même s'ils ont une structure un peu
allumé côté des seconds tours doublé
c'est pas évident pour le genre
d'attaqué de ce côté parce qu'ils ont
moins d'espèces donc automatiquement
quand à moi l'espace des pièces
s'engouffre mois et
donc voilà après ça dépend si tu es une
abeille il avait entre autres aux
espaces verts des abeilles étaient que
j'ai même parfois à vue mme alors un
truc de fou fab faut qu'on en parle
une fois et tu vas y avait une abeille
j'étais sur les îles tu vois qu'est ce
que je fais je mets en bocal dessus je
me dis ça va je l'enfermer tu vois
j'étais confiant ouais dans la croix de
croix de bois croix de fer
c'est ce qu'elle a fait l'asul vaulx
coeur non elle a creusé et elle est
ressortie à côté pour trouver du coup
bah du coup elle n'a pas besoin de
beaucoup d espace non messieurs je les
enfermer je t'en faire mais quand
j'étais heureux mais moi je creuse un
trou je ressens la côte est question à
faire j'étais dans la merde bâle a du
coup bas est ce que visite est une
abeille quoi peut-être h6 ça ressemble à
rien du coup c'est pour faire être cng 5
parce que la cij et 5 direct il faut 3
mais il va te prendre même si ça prend
part avec elle un problème de connexion
me dit oui il un truc rouge
l'important sa connexion pourtant la
caméra c'est bon mais à sa connexion en
sueur pour il a pris en mai deux bons
route le responsable un peu beaucoup
donné pendant les pions ouvert son box
[Musique]
ok mais tu prenons ces trois ans pendant
qu'on y est
où on bouffe à deux plutôt jeu parce
qu'on bouffe ou rien de damas trois quoi
mais ce n'est pas dans l'esprit saint en
femme
ouais ouais ouais mesdames français 3
est tellement de lignes ouvertes après
même si je fais juste un petit jeu c'est
pas d'un mais de deux tours fc 1-1
m'inquiète pas sa pression croît de 6
est vraiment accru de 4 qui tape les
tours le cavalier qui va arriver attendu
mais c'est génial que tu prends ces 3es
au québec chez dams deux tatas bien
manger comme une tumeur le ventre plein
non je ferais tuer x 3 non mais peut
dater jouable tu fais tu trouvé trois
jeux faits d'armes à 5
enfin j'ai de plus en plus comme un fou
après je suis pas super confiant mais
maitient des fois la question que je me
pose c'est est-ce que kita est mal de
toute façon je faire pas avoir deux
pions plus sûr dans l'idée
kita est très droit ouais mais bon si tu
fais damas trois secousses et si bien
aimé damas trois tours des trois bassins
ouais et est retombé 5 m en vais te
faire mal mais c'est évident on nomme à
3/3 mangez pas trop calculer à monsieur
juste le plus futile va faire état d'âme
à 4km america c'est ce qu'on va pas se
prendre une fouine un peu comme coach et
de l'autre jour là la vidéo qu'on a mis
en doute pas mais ça ça nous plaît fab
c'est beau c'est bien joué saddam
prendra au moins y'a pas toi dégage avec
des pions de merde quoi peut-être la
fout c'est un tu vas tu fais la fouine
tu repars tu mastoura trois boîtes par
an à cinq avec la dame en fait
non mais peut-être un truc comme
cavalier des 4 1 pourquoi pas tomber il
est revenu quoi il est revenu fab et
maintenant après ce retour de la tour ça
donne un cours gratuit à visite qui peut
sapri ya deux lectures joue ouais il a
un coût gratuit
bayrou il revient il rejoint un coup de
dames
ça fait quatre fois ça fait quatre fois
d'affilée qui joue sa demie ne fait que
jouer saddamistes nom du coq et
maintenant mais sûre s'il résiste il
fera gagnant deux points de plus c'est
bien un tas de gens à passer pour les
finales mais bon c'est pas trop le sujet
fort pour résister bon il veut rendre un
pion est rentré dans la finale et sur
damas de chance va refaire damas cinq
des nuls des six noms mais tendue
refusant refaire damas 5 et peut-être
toi mais peut-être les cinq tomes ces
cinq mois j'ai tombé 5 pourquoi pas mais
on revient cette fois je trouvais
anormal mais peut-être tour c1 après
femmes et tu penses que tu peux prendre
la vitamine à un moment donné tu
commences à me le plein de coups
d'affilée après bonvalet trouve bien
sachez chaud la personne mais si tu peux
te faire ta db6 mme jelacic jardin des
sens je te comprends même si on persiste
on prend ce but il faut aussi ce matin
au quai à 5 mieux
[Musique]
bah ils menacent ouais mais regarde ni
menacer la tour quel taux la tour b
saint qui protège la casse b3 faut que
tu as fait retour b2 et il est là quoi
il se bat et président c'est fou ces 5
fu b61 meilleurs atours à deux assez
chiante aura deux tours 5b deux équidés
tourbe et de trois de ses chiens aïe
il est dans la merde visite ff5 un effet
tour dames c'est simple je pense et
surfe ou trois dames cced il faut
prendre un set est fou mais c'est ce qui
arrive je pensais finir vous prend à
cette lacérant dont on parle est ok il
va faire ses cinq pas mais bouffe tourbe
et 5 c 4
peut-être bouffe c'est qu'à trouver six
tours à huit matches et je suis comme ça
paraît quand même assez convaincant je
pense on abandonne n'ont toujours pas
comment on peut défendre mais restera
huit mats et et surtout prend c'est
gratuit on prend ces quatre b6 paris est
ce qu il faut et si oui mais pas
d'euphorie mais précisément tours à huit
tours va plus pas faire infuser 6 en
espérant rameuter les témoins prend pour
adultes pour prendre des 8es je fais roi
des huit il va même pas de prendre la
touriste fait tour à 8,9 et méprisent
vie dit pour le moment rien fait
d'envoyer vici ya mon délire passe
comment il a vu mais il n'a pas vaincu
quoi les avais pensé dans les rappels
dans astérix et obélix
car on est un mec qui revient voir césar
ils lui diront à veni vidi vici comme
toujours vécu oui mais veni vidi vici
par un bon fils bon sauveur ouais
pas et tous les humoristes français
france apf alain chabat que oui
monica bellucci humoriste très célèbre
jamel
ouais y avait eric et ramzy aussi je
pense ils ont fait un trou d'un truc me
souviens plus je pense qu'il devait y
avoir à me dire et donc une tétine à
jorf c'est très connu tout ça d'un très
connue je sais pas en même temps je
connaissais la ligne avec h5 mais
peut-être vers le fond une flûte et tous
joué que j'ai six réfugiés cette fois je
connais ici j'ai regardé ya pas
longtemps faveur d'une maxime groupe
thomson tu vois bien tout à fait vrai et
mais juste fait comprendre dès 5 ans
donc là on va être violent lui faut se
ressemblent mais bon rien à voir donc à
4 et j'ai pas compromis ont fait 5 f/4
5-5 puisque je suis pas de faire quatre
moi même je ferais e4 ouais mais bon
coup qu'elle et 4,6 et variés truc c'est
que j'ai pas du tout envie d'enfin je
sais pas comment me sortir ces
structures de faim dans l'ain j'aimerais
bien voir le plus rangée cisco live
comme tu dis elle fois en gsm mais je
sais pas comment se dépatouiller de ce
truc avec le fonds s est en fait parce
que faire rock et a5 donc maxime fm et
le prochain qui tu donnes les cases
blanches a dit donc car sun amy sont
fourbes et 5 il a vu ses quatre vérités
b3 et des prestataires en a3 b3 b5
c'est une partie j'avais fait sur la
chaîne n'ya pas très longtemps mais à 5
c'est un peu une improvisation de maxime
c'était pas une grosse préparation nous
fait remarquer je remarque la même chose
sur la caméra c'est que visite il est
mort de rire en train de se marrer ça
fait marrer tout le match en général de
file mr day très heureux par contre côté
avait non sens que s'il commence à
perdre il va falloir y avoir une écrou
lada sur le sillage
il a failli mène 1 0 il m'a déjà d'être
complètement déprimé coiffe est en train
de se dire ça fait super fichiers alors
qu'on sent xvi dit bon on lui met la
rivière confiance ok bon donc dû
combattre l'énorme délaisse un peu le
länder dame l'autre côté en revanche
c'est trop s'était adria sienne il
ressemble un peu à tigran de la dernière
fois je refuse un peu le même temps le
petro siens ah oui physique un peu
similaire quoi il aurait pu tenter tour
à 3 lutz étroit avec l'enfermement de
dame ça aurait pu être sympa mais le
demande ainsi aux hommes se situe
pouvait pas tenter tout juste 5 bat v
jean tulard beaucoup plus sympa quand
même enfin je pense que si tu vas dîne
avec quelqu'un à de base quand tu as les
caméras t'as plus envie d'aller d'aller
bouffer avec vie dit maman dit plutôt
sympa je vais vue conclut il ya trois
ans deux ans trois ans la capelle il est
encore plus jeune que maintenant mais
déjà 26 20 par l'ajef nuls mais tu sois
port neuf analyser tous eu des souris en
avril tu es content de la partie ouais
mais il a l'air content de tout en fait
ouais c'est bien des gens comme ça bayer
très heureux hasard en fait tu te dis
non plus en plus ce prêt c'est que si tu
perds tu sens qu'il va quand même être
heureux il va pas moi j'aime bien les
voir s'écrouler sur le siège quoi ça me
fait marrer
on le retrouve sa petite toile et le
sourire n'y aura pas de risque oui ou
non alors que adrian tu sens que enfin
même chez lui ça peut devenir sombre
quoi tout fera couler lumières peuvent
s'éteindre
du coup c'est ces pays basque ainsi
visite au prochain tour chez plus contre
qui joue mais dans tous les cas il va
jamais sombrer quoi est on à faire
grand intérêt des matchs de ne pas avoir
le même des centres sa chaise un foyer
sacleux recruté pour la prochaine
classique du coroner un mec toujours
debout quoi si je suis toujours vivant
paf
il était fort dans les petits indiens
aussi en pro de chasse ils ont aidé
sarine de double non je suis pas ne vous
connais pas de ville
voilà cette année je crois qu'ils vont
faire une équipe sarine doubla nom des 3
4 aux deux gamins en fait oui par un peu
chiant mais je crois que pai a pas
encore les règles officielles mais j'ai
cru lire que dans le projet il y avait
un truc pour limiter comme ça la force
des gains dans les gamins qui ont gagné
trop de points ou un truc comme ça on
reprend leur classement en janvier en
fait parce qu'ils ont remarqué l'année
dernière qui est des équipes qui a des
gars à 2000 qui a été passée 2004 comme
à moi une fois j'ai joué de ses congés
volet kaffrine l'échiquier l'a pas le
gamin que j'avais joué il comptait 2180
ou 2002 ils étaient 24 80 quand j'ai
joué j'ai acheté le salar faire pourquoi
ne pas prendre le classement de janvier
reprendre septembre a laissé passer
quatre mois
oui oui mais oui c'est ça non mais je
pense c'est pour pouvoir organiser les
équipes à l'avancé tout mais c'est vrai
qu'en dessous de 18 ans ah ça m'arrive
quand même pas trop chez les adultes n'y
a pas eu de 1 en mai date de 40
oui oui tu peux avoir un très mauvais
classement et après que ça remonte donc
il fallait arriver j'ai lu qu'ils
étaient conscients du problème et qu'ils
cherchaient des régions des solutions un
pur pour pas que ça se reproduise ça
fait un trop trop gros écarts
mais du coup il m'a l'air toujours bien
dit il va mettre le cavalier en c4 mais
je ne peux pas mieux les noirs sur cette
dame mais bon il faut faire critiquer je
fais rembourser on est devant avec et
j'oublie qu'il faut jusqu'à quand il ya
la tour qui est protégé la dame qui est
protégé bon et quand bien même il peut y
avoir encore de la fouine ria peut-être
damage 6 à la fin et font encore free tu
peux encore fragile va mais on valide et
d'autres celui du ps veut un espace à
nous arrivons bon ça arrange mais la
chose selon les pour visite en fait dans
le chat de wade je suis pour vidic est
ce qu'on peut faire un truc chelou moi
je veux être un peu too much mais
c'était pour sg 1 pour ses huîtres
angers7
pour prendre le set de 1.17 va croire
j'ai un os qui ont inquiété de moi mais
la dame s'infiltrer le plus raide 5 pts
2/6
j'ai pas c'est pas on n'a peut-être pas
besoin de faire un truc comme sa mère
quittent idée marrante noter que prend
1,5 et les affaires puis on prend je
pense ouais bon sens mais d'autres pays
et 5 contre
mais j'ai pas je sens qu'on peut
combiner sur qui on comprend qu'il faut
voir des trucs avec la 6e rangé je sais
pas quoi parce que la dame du coup elle
va jouer à l'euro à ndam coiffe dallest
prend soin et vous fait cinquante
premiers bouts b6 non ouais alors avec
quoi vous avec la dame personnes
voilà il va devoir trouver the way mais
attend le prendre à 5
il va reprendre des deux mais j'ai
l'impression que c'était pas très bon en
fait cette histoire puisse le faire
c'est 4 1 je peux faire c'est 4 mais bon
je me prends du contre jeu de partout
lvf 4 et tout ça va arriver raconte
ressources visuelles mais à première vue
non c'est non mais c'était pas c'est pas
que visuel le problème c'est que la dame
blanche et les hyper mal plaçant à cinq
elle revient pas en jeu femme peut-être
damas est alors mes congés droit prend
b2 bref 2 3 je suis pas contre nature
faire une position carapace en ramenant
à l'étude relève 4 3 mais je voudrais
2007 mais pas grand chose en fait être
un juste peut-être faire fou des quatre
écoutes pas acheter que c'est dégueu
mais tu es des fois faut se rendre à
l'évidence il faut des gars dit encore
le tour j'ai devant moi prend food et 4
d'un bébé de 2 me prends des quatre oui
c'est ce que je disais c'est dégueu mais
je préfère d'amd de enfin deux variantes
tu vois mais je vois pas de qui on voit
sa peau ne tombe plus d'injections
problème non grâce à tour mais voyez
très heureux quand même ok peut-être
qu'il va voir dan d2 avec ses 4
la seconde à ckoi renault ils disent ah
ben il avait le choix entre le talent
d'harmonia nous le physique d'arreau
nian il n'a rien pris même pas si je
suis mise
c'est vrai que c'est assez moche non
mais ça fait vraiment contraste avec
visite qui paraît sympa souriant beau
gosse tu vois quand même c'est le
contraste est violent quoi entre le fils
inc aronian et son talent il ya une
chaufferie l'arrêt un prix qui sont
fantastiques dans le château sont
vraiment méchants quoi c'est génial on
va peut-être fou b2g paris se défend bah
c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait visite
bah oui la trouve un truc intéressant
reste mal je pense mais bon mais c'est
bizarre c'est un peu tourné quoi alors
que ça ne te fait sauter super là avant
on peut s'attendre
peut-être qu'il est mieux qu'il est
moins bien et attesteront dommage pour
la can je pensais quand même très marias
pas de menaces pas d'un premier enfant
pendant à perpète mais il est souvent un
jeu je pense au projet d'un proche cinq
pays on demande toi j'ai rien compris
aulas a beau nul nul nul fab
le ton y est faut donner un
mais le problème c'est qu elle fut matée
folle 4 stevo quest ix
trente mecs mêlant 2d bon visite faut
qu'on sache ce que rennes 2 0 c'est pas
des vieux rêves et surtout qualité bien
ici a choisi du respect pour avesnes
messieurs dont on aime bien on rigole
enfin patron reconnaît qu on essaye
surtout de rigoler un petit peu loin
mais il me rappelle vraiment petrosyan
ccsa du corps et de poing il a l'image
il a l'image du petrosyan qui s'étaient
faits qui s'étaient tellement je vais
marcher marcher dessus par karl celle il
ressemble vraiment du coup j'ai cette
image de petrosyan qui glisse dans son
siège
donc on est petite italienne j'ai envie
de te dire j'ai envie de te dire vie dit
quand même tu sens que tu sens qui
rigole moins quand même tu vois non mais
refusons qu'il est encore très heureux
mais plus haut point de sourire tu vois
moi sont peu beauf et ses pions je
prends des cinq ans peut-être faire d'un
pro sky prend qu'il prend 1,5
david utah un piège c'est qu'il prend
pour preuve deux rois prendre à 9,6 me
like hell ride et sur quelle f4 sinon je
sais pas te le phocéen qui traînait je
sais pas mais on peut être reprendre
juste d'apprendre mais tout allait bien
écoutez en tout cas la farce coréen
voilà au moins une telle hémorragie
parce que tu as sont moins 2 c'est pas
énorme sur une phase mais bon quand tu
commenceras deux défaites de suite ma
chance et un bon début de match quand tu
te dis visage marqué un demi point jeu
m'avait choqué une partie d'échecs où il
fane enfin match tu prends 10 0
d'affilée c'est sûr en france mais ma
souffrance si cela déjà oui mais jamais
un livre là un fable voient leur nombre
est ce qu'on peut avoir des dames
détroit c'est un peu petit bras quand
même un assez petit noir mais bon ça va
il faut pas été promu e cat way c'est sa
demande parce qu'elle est le pur f2 qui
peut être en prise derrière ça peut être
chaud femmes non mais c'est pas fou 3 ça
va tu veux pas trouver d autres non plus
tu perds quatre tu te fait changer les
dames 1 écoute entame peut être trop en
vigueur contrôler la seule colonne de
l'échiquier pas vraiment terrible est ce
ça va philippe pas qu'on ait mis non
plus parce qu'il serait cool c'est
d'apprendre à me prends des trois tours
prend des trois quarts à nicher 3 je me
dirige vers f5 à ton franc g3 pas de
chance riscle au pays basque plus il pas
quand il a vu peut-être on peut faire
moins recette en train de plonger si
c'est plus d'entrées peut-être
quoiqu'elle et h5 peut-être tour des
huit évidemment ma plein plein d'idées
du père de possibilités bon les blancs
et bezina aucune n'a aucun rapport avec
une chaîne youtube
la jeune d'options ouais mais tu n'y
fait sa chaîne donc du coup tu as jeu à
leurs idées fait sa chaîne finir il le
crée mais dont on peut tout c'est un
échec
là c'est génial quand on a chauffé les
gens dans le chatt quoi il chausse sur
rennes peut arrêter de le critiquer
convaincu il s'en fout on fait parler
les gens très attention là on va donc
une petite personne je sens ma faim
concrètement leur partir mais dont qui a
provoqué le petit bis
est-ce qu'on n'est même pas pied par
envie de le jouer le d5
j'ai envie de te dire on ne sait pas
fabre nord se tape tout réhabiliter à 4
tu vois moi je serais quand même tenté
par mes vieux démons j'aurais peut-être
g5 turin a fait un bref du cros le faire
un truc sur f2 van megen farfouille 3 sa
suite me refroidir
mais j'y crois pas du tout en un mois je
me serais senti obligé de le faire toi
faut le faire ok on en voit mais des
fois ça marche un de faire ça en blitz
de faire un truc complètement ridicule
comme ça comme g5
la petite sphère tour des huit femmes et
et cavaliers ou saccagés si c'est un
jour mais il ya le sud y associant
peut-être qu'à et 17 f 6 et cavalli c5
qui va peut-être être redirigé cavaliers
6 6 verset 5 pts est pas con ça j'aime
bien cette idée femme belle et je vois
thierry 17 femmes un cahier 17 c'est
souvent une bobine r2 retransféré
après-vente ward et 8,5 ou très
raisonnable et maintenant qu'est 17 je
suis sûr que c'est un bon coup fab c'est
bien je pense qu'il a fait ça pour toi
d'ailleurs le flou mais si ce nom c'est
bien joué c'est bien joué mais en fait
ouais ça commence à prendre un peu plus
forme pour les normes parce que si tu
commences à l'attaqué b3 bon bah c'est
cool
c'était bien joué sont fous des 6es du
coup peut-être le cavalier des deux
convoqués b5 ce n'est pas très joyeux
quoi il a souhaité un truc confère à
tout un conteneur enfin quand on a ça a
toujours un coup nos clients d'une case
d'envisager que coup d'après valeur
repoussée d'encore d'une case c'est un
truc qu'on peut facilement oublier oui
mais c'est ça va ce qui lui arrive et tu
vas bien de rugby situé quai 2 tu pense
peut-être pas trop à bessens aller à
peut-être voir les collines touron b1
est donc d un brownie là il a colmaté
mais bon d'armand les blancs sous
pression
j'avais fait le petit f6 marie noëlle
têtu faire le cavalier moqué sur cassis
les trois accords n'ont pu faire c'est
aussi pour des sets qui est 18 e 6 de
faire tiquer bien placer mon sens je
pense que ça sera grand chose parce
qu'avec les blancs et fait quand même du
g3 roigé deux là pour te plaindre qu'un
maillage de jeu qu il va en f1 trois
peut-être même une tête cavaliers si
cela est à + g3 et à tout reprend j'ai
trois plata puis j'ai trois femmes n'en
peut plus tout le tu dois faire car il
est des f3 pour essayer de colmater ce
que tu peux mais qui n'a pas été très
influent dans ce parti tactiquement
andrésiens pilori des petits coups comme
ça il ajouté
la normale mais c'est pas plutôt
positionne allemand fait qu'il a été un
peu léger
finalement ben non mais qui est des deux
baies 5 ouvert le cavalier h2 ceux des
fautes un peu plus tactique parce que tu
te dis oui piégé 3 puis vraiment une là
bas sinon on fait recaler h2k et 5 à 3
ça va quand même plus raisonnable
elle doit refaire tour des deux noms g3
maintenant arrêter ces cinq là ils
rendent la caisse et 5 c'est chiant je
fais revenir vers détroit tu as le pion
mais ça c'est des positions que je joue
bien généralement femmes
ouais c'est pas mal de manoeuvres de
petites tactiques et c'est intéressant
ouais ses dépositions que gère que je
gère pas mal bouffe burqa et des trois
ans que j'aurais dit du coup on attaque
b4 deux fois je vois même pas comment
défend et monaco je le prendrais tu vois
pas un but lors des deux tours vient
d'être un coup aussi tu voudrais
commencer par tour b1 et pour essayer de
prendre des cas tv d enfer ou encore
manu triste 12e temps des rois vers un 0
6 3 avant de faire tout ça mais tout est
très bien ce qu'il fait aussi ses ventes
à ses gambettes g4 ils seraient
affaiblis va se rendre cavaliers f4 en
fait c'est l'impression que sa veine il
a dans cette partie je crois qu'il a
tout fait à l'envers non
même tes preuves de ce surnom peu votre
web mais bon non mais c'est sûr c'est
pas mauvais mais est-ce que tu as
vraiment envie de m'arrêter de jouer
c'est dire si fr thouars bien tomber
deux c'est ça qui est ça pousse tout
c'est peut-être hyper simple eric
gaillard y fier à nantes a raison
quel massacre cette partie ouais ok sa
violence
qu'est-ce qui va tenter sa veine il a
tenté kg qu'après h6 et j'ai pas trouvé
un contre jeu ouais après il tente le
va-tout non il tente le bateau mais
enfin ça va tout jouer à l'échec pas
exigé en fait c'est le va tout a même
pas une pièce actifs wassef va tout en
lui son suicide
puis ces deux squats je pense que la
fille sans détour geffroy match fou des
cas tellement possibilités
et il a quoi il ya quatre pions mais
trop sous des capes
j'ai rarement vu des policiers avec
autant d'options de plus non mais aucun
soin est jeté ses tournées un peu la
montre comme il al avantage au bo moi je
reçois un peu parce qu'il raconte ado
est en fait j'ai pas vu les logiciels la
i10 quoi comme dans le film trois mecs
visite légèrement favori je sais je le
rappelle plus là du coup de fouet
bizarre on la joue aussi longtemps
voilà comment vous lamentez au foot fait
la montre a fait huit minutes de jeu le
thème d'êtres humaines à zéro mais on
s'en passer des choses dans mes visites
manière tellement confiant au petit
juste confiant tout le temps faim qu'il
a c'est peut-être que même pas dire
qu'ils soient confiants pas ces trois
noms tiens je pense que tu es content de
l'avoir quand tu joue par équipes aidés
des gages de bonne chose pour l'équipe
ouais l'âge des cinq postulats parfait
mais il n'est pas le grand esprit de
puni quoi pour songer 6 très timide la
peintre grec e5 là ce n'est pas possible
enfin tu prends quand même beaucoup d
espace avec 5 ouais mais apprendre très
vite un os 4 le fica besson et revient
vers ses serres mais bon on sera autour
du dogme c'est un faux chili ce qui est
des dockers 4 ça se regarde bien 25 juin
je pense ça va exister d'air
tant qu'elle a fait était mangement
gentil des faca les huit imagine quatre
soeurs logique tu peux pas calé duo 6
malheureusement mais j'aime bien moi je
dépense toujours plus
comme c'est un jeu auquel les deux après
tu peux faire foi h2 et faire un peu
comme fin tu peux la joue un peu grâce à
londres contre des quatre en fait
constitué au chantier tout de même il ya
des barons tout à part la diagonale
ouvert faire c'est plutôt un tournoi
rend le 5 mai tu joues sur le fait que
les foucades noir se se neutralisent pas
mais à vrai dire souvent comme un pion
de saint-cloud g7 il tire un peu la
gueule et la ville fait le cavalier en
d5 vous amène alors est ce que l'on fait
cavalier g5 qui avait lieu 4 après il a
joué avec à 4 bon il faut stopper les et
de baies 5 c 4
c'est de jouer dan des trois mais je
pense qu'avec le 4 assez vite en fait
mais à quatre thématiques jean position
les huit baies 5 des fois tu feras à 5,6
faible et 6 pour défendre ces cinq fois
la france on parle à juste un pion mais
peut être utilisé pour casser la
structure
donc c'est pas mauvais coup mais tu peux
marquer ses 4 et a54 attaquer ces cinq
je sais pas mais oui je me rêvais déjà
forfait pour les gens qui regardent via
la chaîne l'istrie mois il faut aller
sur sur la chaîne chaise comme c'est
juste un hébergement sur la chaîne du
stream c'est un truc que permet de faire
twitch fable qui est assez bien c'est
d'ailleurs pour la peine c'est que
tu peut héberger sur ta chaine une autre
chaîne en fait sauf que la parole sur la
chaîne vitrine twitch les gens si tu as
qui aurait pu penser que tu as été sur
la chaîne bitstream ce live puisque only
boys connexes y voit ça quand même
et ça c'est vrai que c'est pas mal déjà
si demain tu vas faire un live sur une
autre chaîne que tu as invité ou quoi tu
peux tout ce que je veux dire mais tu
peux le faire sur tâche face hébergé en
même temps tu as pas le même chat et
tout ça mais tu ça paraît que les gens
en fait ils trouvent le stream quoi bon
mais ben c'est pas mal mais là ça c'est
un quart des femmes c'est une option
logique mais je pense que ça revienne un
peu moins bien enfin j'aime bien ce pion
aux cinq personnes à la fin 2005
maintenant presque on bouffe bouffer
cavaliers 3 briscoe qui a valu aux trois
directs moi je vais peut-être que trois
directs en fait moi je ne sais pas
changer grand chose qu'on va vous fait
autant mais j'aime bien garder la
flexibilité si je peux après peut-être
une raison pour laquelle il a pris
direct je serai la même gamme allant de
trois femmes mais repart en d2 bassoues
fric et de trois piliers qui prend tout
reprendre en 31 parties prenantes avant
je sais pas mais et s'est pas battu
garder les pièces quand avons plus d
espace les cailloux trois stops et man
il va faire ses c4 nalaïeva c4 beau
quand même faire je suis surpris par ce
coupé quatre femmes mais c'est peut-être
parce que ce qui est en l'air en fait
ont besoin bref je pensais qu'ils
allaient défendre par ces quatre puisque
la wii est ce que je vais faire ces
quatre cavaliers b3 tu vois ducati rond
car il y en avait 3 et super bien placé
je tiens la casse des cadres j'attaque
le pion c5
non mais y avait trois hommes sur
christophe des cinq qui avait trahi la
dame prendre des photos à l'appui
oui quand bien même on pourrait faire
qu'il prend ses seins il serait pas
perdu une qualité doit vous faire mais
non mais tu vas jamais faire ça non
si tu le vois tu vois jamais faire mais
si tu vois pas t'es pas perdant je veux
faire quoi est ce qu'on fait quand même
quatre pieds le capteur ok j'ai aussi eu
des cas du g4 peut-être notoire foot est
roi des parents perdus ouais mais
peut-être du kuga et b3 sur foot est roi
non justin kiewit hockey rap faut qui
nous là je suis un faux lac et mieux je
préfère toujours le blond bas mais ses
paroles sont fous en jeu des risques il
aurait pas eu intérêt directement à
geoffoy jaunes et rouges et trois jeux
théâtre théâtre
quatre vingts vous tournerez mirage de
effectivement après le truc pas mal en
cash sans gaieté becker en quatre sets
2-6 qui marcheront attendons on nous dit
qu'on est déjà mis là sur le live qu'est
ce que c'est que cette merde
est ce que c'est possible qu'on soit
1000 non mais attends je vais regarder
non mais je fais très attention à ce
chat parce que 1000 mais on et 1008 fab
minutes
ben quoi fabrice que tu es une légende
je crois pas marie quand tu peux être
1008 sur 100m welz en avais tu as des
fois je me dis mon parent wayne et bien
lui en valais on a les émoticônes
quoique moins 1900 on est retombé à 900
on est retombé à 9 sur les gens les gens
sont partis et son duo plus un parfum
fois h2 manager 4 on peut rouler pour
l'ag 4 non mais ça va être la folie
quand il va y avoir une vue elle n'a
qu'à pas je te jure qu'on peut être
peut-être 2000 ou 3000 ou 4000 depuis
spa ça va être la folie pure
pour reprendre il ya des seniors il a
bien compris notre humour il a dit femme
nommée caf sans doute toronto ne s'est
pas tu vois plutôt non mais ce n est qu
en me brossant les douala le brossant
les dents brossant les dents la dernière
fois enfin dans la vidéo que j'ai mis ce
matin je pense que j'ai fait
en terme de connerie quand même c'est tu
vois je pense que je me suis quand même
je vais quand même très loin tu vas
femmes mais très content de la photo que
j'ai posté les jeunes il est très
heureux
mais d'ailleurs j'attends que les gens
fassent ça coûte les hashtag et ou quoi
qu'attendez-vous d'ailleurs fab
il va y avoir un cadeau je sais que
yatch à ce point com qui offre un
abonnement diamants ainsi aujourd'hui
ouais si vous vous poster en train de
regarder avec le hashtag speech est ce
donc je vais mettre le hashtag dans le
dans le bain dans le truc à hashtag
#civsocial et avec ce hashtag vous allez
sur twitter vous prenez une photo pour
montrer comment est ce que vous regardez
le match donc essayer de faire un truc
original il soir que les mecs vous
filent à un abonnement très bonne
initiative
la tvh la colonne a besoin surtout à
huit clos qui consiste en une fois son
équipe rend pas compte qu'il faut bien
qu'ils aient des 80000 à tomber cette
attaque et tu vois mon dilemme je vois
ton dilemme est peut-être juste fait
retour à un tour à cette femme c'est
quand tu fais torah il veut pas il veut
peut-être faire jouer autour an prochain
non mais moi je jouais tour à 8 avec
l'énorme statue vers tous azimuts avec
les noirs ne marche pas c'est donc ça je
voulais faire tout un mythe
ouais bah c'était peut-être plus inspiré
que lecavalier 6 2 amène du coup alors
savane femme je crois qu'en pro de chez
sig qui joue avec les armées ouais très
beau film et c'est pour ça qu'il a
peut-être le grand coup avec lui quoi je
pense que quand artaq avec toi c'est
presque tchité n'ont sûrement si nous
avions artaq je pense qu'on aurait de
grandes chances de gagner cette
compétition soit sur le toit du monde
comme au pire - le toit de l'europe
ouais enfin on lui proposait je pense un
contrat assez juteux 20 milliards artaq
viens avec nous car tac sauve nous sauve
nouvelle nous il était génial dans l'est
dans les interviews un fou
du stand et toute l'énergie qu'elle sait
jamais ce qu'il vous est défoncée à
toutes les parties mais il était super à
chevaux qu'elle soit les rigoler ce jour
là avec artaq arts à kaarst accéder
comme des fous que je ramène de ça ça
serait beau conte ici même l'an prochain
pour de vrai quoi baba on est l'équipe
way serait fantastique
je ferai les fusils des interviews deux
d'entre eux match non ce serait
fantastique comme vous joueriez fisher
et la faire le con pendant le truc avec
le t-shirt bitstream de partout ce que
dit et tu te donnes et alors on aurait
le truc un blockbuster the maire de
wasquehal bugbusters et par greenstream
mais j'ai demandé un changement non et
ça m'a pas été là corner accordé pour le
moment non en fait ils ont 10 bis rim ça
veut rien dire
ben jarry pourquoi de chasse grâce à
dire quelque chose soit quelque chose
bah je sais pas mais je comprends pas en
fait pourquoi eux ils ont leur nom et
nous allons enfin pas je comprends pas
en fait moi c'est toujours pareil on est
persécuté la diversité de partout que
c'est horrible je veux que cette équipe
s'appelle litres il faut agir ça nous
représentent plus que block busters en
fait mais je veux que ce soit des
commandes tant d'idées mais pourquoi pas
en fait même bien c'est pas moins le
glossaire pour ceux qui ont osé mais oui
j'ai proposé les guépards et je vois
comment on fait toujours les chats et
toujours rien n'est très rapide
j'ai regardé que le félin le plus rapide
c'est le guépard ouais
et comme on fait toujours les chats je
suis ok si vous voulez un nom un peu
marrant on ce délégué par oui non ça n'a
aucun rapport avec can't buy me lever
d'ici bas d'amérique départ je t'en
faire les jeux cinq femmes si je suis un
guépard je suis un guépard fadjri
qu'est-ce que j'y peux moi si on se sent
guépard un peu plus sentir provenance
genre blockbuster fmi oui festival du
film banon ouais d'accord c'est un
rapport c'est ça rapporte as tu avais
pas compris assez génial non mais quel
logo ce cas pourquoi pas pour monnaies
locales
du coup je te la prend voilà en fait il
est là le rapport fo h2 peut-être
tourner ça peut-être caïds et de
cailloux 4 les cavaliers 5
les gagnants mais inquiet des deux kim
cattrall et on a ramé ok mais il faut
replacer son cavalier ton temps annuler
vie dit null null null quoi heureusement
avec c'est toujours mieux mais guérit et
2 k -o 4 mais qu'est ce que tu fous et
voilà le cassis et bien non il va gagner
chance
quoi qu'il en soit et quand bien même
quoi ouais mais il va se prendre la tour
en b3 n'ont finalement tu as dû échanger
ce fou pour y est pas tellement le
délire là on est très énervé ou pas mais
tu as trois des quatre encore je sais
pas si tu te fais échanger f tus va
pousser ces noms mais la cfi des deux
gros orteils ce marché est très heureux
mais très frêle il a fait une petite
grimace cannes le bon mais l'air heureux
quand même nom mais je suis très heureux
de visites soit sérieusement je vais lui
écrire après le match que j yi he will
we are the thing for players pas je dis
si on l'a dans l'équipe on sera heureux
même mais en fait il y de ça ils
cherchent à jean top 12 ont reçu le ok
donc timminco toile votre me faut un
casting compétitionne mais tu sais que
je veux faire un truc de ouf en fait
femmes
ouais si on recrute qui tue c'est oui le
plus avec le plus gros palmarès
ok enfin papa seules fins palais moggi
quoi l'autre ouais ouais en fait je veux
l'écrire tu écriras l'équipe et tous à
tous les journaux pour dire que ok quand
une équipe française a signé l'un des
tout meilleurs joueurs d'échecs du monde
et tous dans l'équipe et c'est du jamais
vu en fait pas assez du déjà vu mais je
veux dire que j'avais mais récemment
récemment nom est donc en fait de dire
que ça c'est la plus forte équipe
française c'est fantastique en fait mais
ok c'est sûrement vrai parce que en fait
je veux dire pas c'est l'équipe qui joue
la position la plus prestigieuse louis
le nord où il ya des meilleurs joueurs
au monde est sain une position mondiale
selon forbes le coupe du monde des clubs
et je vais je veux aussi aller voir la
mairie de cannes que faire parler de
nous de partout quoi faire un choix dans
les journaux ouais bah en fait
offrez-vous une ville ocre marc madiot
et on parle de kiba on parle de
quelqu'un dont on ne dira pas c'est un
peu si tu veux c'est un peu le délire
harry potter tu vois c'est à dire qu'on
parle on sait qui on sait qui on parle
ou tu vas mais comment peuvent
malheureusement je peux le dire mais bon
on a vu que ya rien de fait avec le
ballon ça se fera pas pour 5 à 2 à
soirée du coup ce serait l'inversé plus
gros palmarès qu'elle veut elle plus
gros palmarès calvaire c'est c'est quand
même au dessus il a fait ce qu'on veut
ferme en web et frébault aussi
évidemment ni france à quoi doivent
juste une aura français mais mais
beaucoup de goût et sa jambe élite dont
on parle non mais elle édite aussi mais
c'est un mec qui a joué les candidats
non mais je conçois vandal est
évidemment mais sarah qui a joué les
candidats on va vous en dire plus parce
qu'après sinon on dit juste le nom
collation année de plus mais c'est un
maquillage les candidats
donc en fait ces femmes ça qui est très
connue balle fab
bon ça pourrait être un arthur tueur
mais bon vlad ces quand même trop
enfin bon on est toutes chances aux
autres équipes ouais ça sert mais
croisons pas la compétition de le
mercato mais ça me gênerait par rapport
aux organisateurs de la prochaine ligue
de faire jouer feu à vlad fin à c'est un
peu comme les sky après au tour de
france quoi tu te fais tu as regardé la
compet sur un succès d'avancé qui a
gagné c'est c'est embêtant quoi c'est
gênant vivant après tu te retrouves avec
une ombre enfin non mais c'est un gros
palmarès
si génial il a en fait tu sauras bsol
quoi le mettez une grande chaîne youtube
veut des îles plus connu que toi
il pensait pas fallait y penser quoi les
mecs là bas serait fantastique de faire
jouer y penser avec le mec qu'on pense
et en fait si on met notre fantastique
devant avec qui penseurs et on gagne les
matches quand même pas c'est génial avec
0 sur 4 long mariage ils pensaient sûr
très intéressante
d'ailleurs on peut faire pour le délire
c'est très con mais c'est dans notre
style quand même mais non en fait
j'adore fondé des idées débiles comme ça
c'est génial
les idées les plus cons du mou dans les
a tout le temps donc bah écoute chance
aux arènes il a de nouveau dû mal enfin
il se heurte un mur aux granges way se
heurte au gange fab
c'est vrai que me dit un de ganges tu
vois on sent le tueur on sent un rapport
sur le tour en plus ou moins et du coup
je savais que face à sète à cette
rivière sacrée il a beaucoup de mal à
passer quoi
qu'evra après je suis pas non plus ultra
inquiets par les blancs à vincent giret
il est dans le gange face aux gangs
peut-être aurais-je 8
ouais tu as if
bon fab cherche une idée pour les blancs
je trouve rien mais bon pas risquer sur
les contenus et le plan avec damas a
alors sur français 5
est ce que c'est une couille prendre du
plomb et de se faire des pions triper
pour taper sur la colonne ne sera pas tu
as sûrement trop trop coût du kwh moi je
l'aurais fait c'est sûr c'est trop de
sucre
tu prend du plomb et c'est peut-être pas
une faute un fab me le faire être 5 en
force où ces droits sont directement là
je pense à m
il en a rien à [ __ ] avec les noirs
mais ok mais tu peux quand même pas
faire face tu fais 5 c'est quand même tu
as quand même une paire de couilles en
acier en acier trempé qua non mais
s'estompe l'orateur me bouffe à bout
vous vous me le prends pas un assez beau
fab
mais l'équation comprend pions
17 janvier en g8 à défendre tout temps
mais je vais défendre comme google voir
des pièces très passive par ok mais tu
vas prend quand même bref syncra si tu
prends pas on va au moins tu n'as pas le
temps dans les ardennes il est très très
chaud quoi allait remettre les clients
j'ai dit non mais là on est pour avesnes
qu'enfin c'est trop dans l'esprit fab
non megan fox comme ultra pratique
brimer grc dans l'esprit il s'engage
avec des champions ballard attend enfin
dame b 8
on défend tous je vois pas comment tu
passes avec les mains et le jour ios 5
est enfin que je savais que j'avais
l'oeil quoi dam des huit dames des
fuites tout re fou de 8
mais bon tu es tu peux pas après tu fais
pas mieux après peut-être est bloqué
elle est ce qu'on à risque on sort
laisse les les tifos avesnes quoi enfin
même les tifos artaq la ccc artaq est ce
qu'il est en train de faire mon plein
milieu d'un flottement bah oui faut
comparer ce qui se passe en fait mais je
fais un jeu sans attaque peut-être
d'alger si son sac fils adam les dames
c'est de la merde ne prendre aucun
membre honoraire de cinq ans je crois
que ça va juste pas du tout pour les
plus pressés génial voyez chaque épreuve
si cela comme une menace mais brio
gemena musée 5
mais ni de faire kg 3 tours g7
t'abandonne kouame hockey ici s'approche
de l'écran là il comprend pas que ma
fille sunny chou pointu inquiet voire tu
menaces quoi tu menaces dame projet de
hockey d'alger de leur tour je pense
mais on apprend en ce sens que fais tu
sais rien enfin il n'y a peut-être pas
tort j'ai quatre ou cinq corps g7 au
repreneur cinq ans autour de pièces bien
et c'est un rôle un roi c'est secure
passé pour les morts
qui est aux anges et 4 dames un tour
j'ai 2 mg non en revanche c'est
dangereux
non mais ils jouent bien à ils étaient
des cadres et ils ont des cadres et
ronda merde bon je vois même je vais au
cam nou on est bien cadré je fus le
tirage
bon allez c'est parti pour tanger caf
damage 5.5 pour g7 en congé nous devons
apprendre
bon je prends un atour évidemment une
tour saint nicolas aux vertus prend du
roi tu fais fou et imite les âges pour
qu'ils évitent ces purges en moi je suis
restée cinq personnes dont qui est très
bien si nous descendons pas ce qu'il
veut bada sans lancer gagnant c'est trop
fort un tour de pièces comme dame
surtout eu égard à moi aussi j stable et
la dame et tout ça ne va pas faire 50
menace tout seul s'il ya des pièces avec
elle ou quoi ok je ne sais pas mais une
dame sall non non je vois là c'est pas
mal ça je serais pour l'instant paris
son ex naples et liverpool assez chaud
liverpool c'est peut-être la pire équipe
que tu puisse prendre du deuxième
chapeau en mai son chapeau 3 et sur
chapeau 3 liverpool
non mais c'est du vol comment tu
méchament liverpool chapeau 3 merga et
famfamfam fable adama n'arrivant à sept
buts encaissés huîtres et des moules à
dakar après mesdames c5
oui mais bon du coup l'attaquant
stéphanois ont tué mais j'aime pas trop
dessin en fait je trouve qu'il a way il
affaiblit sa carapace et si c'est le cas
et des 6es mais peut-être dante 5 et des
sites damas sept cavaliers 4e français
s'est tu ailles le feu ce cadre est très
sombre mais génie quand elle emprunte au
registre mais oui des cinq un peu toute
cargaison de marcher vers damas est
c'est ce qu'on a prévu ou d'amd quatre
dames des quatre peut-être tu t'en
prends un peu option à 4 et tu protèges
pour le moins quatre dames des quatre
pas con
alors c'est ce qu'il fait bon alors là
quand les temps les joueurs commencent à
faire ce qu'on dit fab mauvais non mais
on doit dire un nouveau truc qui a
commencé pendant le l'asim que phil cup
c'est que tu dois dire qui peut nous
parler
cherchez plus personne ne peut te parler
après voilà qui est prendre quatre noms
et ouais bruges était inactif pas actif
un mois du coup de réactiver quand je
suis actif et prend aux 4 je reviens je
suis à vannes du coup la pression dans
le sens du côté bleu j'aime beaucoup
moins de blacks et prend 1,4 c'est ce
qu'on pensait femmes que nous permet
alors à personne nous par ailleurs fou
prend un f5 on va pas pouvoir vous
parler peut-être qu'il y ait des deux
kf3 pour organiser un m'attend angers
angers un vrai caïd et john organise le
mérite mais qui peut nous parler presque
été de ses 6 et 6 soit c'est sûr mais je
l'espère vous utilisez de faire front et
cinq employés c'est d'avoir floué quatre
mois aux quatre mêmes idées et kf3 tout
revient à dieu bon il revient au score à
3-2 en fin 2002 nous alors pour ceux qui
viennent d'arriver qui sont nouveaux
c'est le pitch assez la plus forte
compétition d'échecs sur internet et le
truc c'est qu'on est en train de
regarder un match entre visites donc un
très fort joueur indien
john qui a été sélectionné et adrian qui
est un des joueurs qui s'est qualifié il
s'est qualifié via une des deux places
qualificatives donc censé être moins
fort quand même hein mais mais très
dangereux
il a vécu au jeu sur internet ce rôle
sportello 5000 jeunes exactement cette
mission il doit relier deux parties il a
été champion du monde juniors quand même
avesnes à l'époque où le championnat du
monde junior c'était était plus fort que
maintenant c'est que maintenant aux
échecs fêter une mona il faut le dire
aussi pour les nouveaux c'est que les
les compétitions de jeunes en fait
bizarrement les meilleurs participe plus
ce qu'ils donnent à leurs familles ouais
mais bon écoute ils vont faire des open
et on faire des trucs fort aussi là mais
tu te rappelles gary la cam était
championne junior par exemple puis bien
sûr non mais même ils vont tous deux
jouaient tout ça va tout seul tout le
monde oui oui
mv la faible quand il joue un plan avec
cinq cavaliers 4 et donc le match va
durer encore il ya des segments en cinq
5 minutes plus une troisième plus une et
unique plus une et le match là va encore
durer à peu près deux bonnes heures
et là on est dans le segment 5 + 1 il
reste 32 minutes de ce segment là est
pour le moment le score est de 2 et demi
deux ans et demi donc égalité parfaite
mais sur la dynamique du match je pense
que le joueur indien est un peu
au-dessus fable visite moi oui il était
mal parti mais non j'ai essayé de
recadrer
je vais essayer de recadrer les joueurs
ah oui n'était pas très bien parti
visite comme le lièvre et la tortue
tf1 peut on obliger de faire pour
s'éviter un peu c'est pas de gaîté de
coeur mais on peut être qu'il faut faire
après dans ce genre de position vous par
trop peur contre cabillaud 4 il est dur
à attraper faudrait enlever le cas des
f3 faire f3 mais on ne viendra la cage
et 3,6 kg et 3 pas rompre en d4
et si on la perd du temps dans le temps
de faire 6 alors pas là et qu'une avant
m b 3 6 à 3 au 4 mai mais bon
normalement ce genre qui se fait
quasiment jamais attrapé fabien un truc
qui me chagrine un peu pour avesnes je
vais te le dire comme ça de but en blanc
fait attention c'est sincère ça à tomber
sur la gueule au moins tu as hautmont je
vais le dire tu tu vas pas fait attendre
mais néanmoins je trouve qu'il a assez
mal préparés dans les ouvertures
j'ai pas regardé c'était parti mais t'as
vu comment ça tu es tombé dessus
ouais j'ai lâché une info là comme ça
t'as vu tu étais tu n'étais pas sur tes
gardes qua non mais ça serait pas
surprenant prince dire que le mec a un
répertoire qui peut pas aller contre
jour de l'élite mais c'est sûrement plus
tôt un joueur d'auch peine les open tu
sais le but c'est de gagner tour n'a pas
de bien figurer pas vaut mieux gagner 3
open parents et finir 50e d'un hacker
j'exagère 50e mairie est loin que de
faire que de faire dix fois qu'il faut
10e c'est un peu comme au poker quelque
part vers parce que qu'elle est grosse
prise deux premières places donc finir
10e ok tu n'as rien enfin trois fois
rien alors qu'il ya deux tournants qui
lui prend bien et sur cette légende open
le jeu beaucoup plus risqué que les gens
de l'élite qui font que des nuls parce
que bon ce sont eux ce qui compte à
présent gardé leurs lots et très vite et
les années d'après reprendre le truc
donc c'est une démarche différente du
coup du coup voilà c'est vachement plus
agressif c'est plus et j'affronte ce jeu
des modernes des trucs un peu tu vois ok
c'est pas la merde bien sûr mais bon que
tu prends ta chance un petit peu comme
toi oui parfum moi oui j'ai pas un jour
de trop qui fait des tons affirmé non
toi tu étais personnes ouvertes pour ça
que les joueurs d'open qui montrent
assez haut comme seedorf ou qu'a pu
faire ou je prends soin
un corps 9 rue ce qu'ils vivent et puis
en tournée ce pagne étaient 26 70 quand
on entend que des open où tu joues des
mac à 2002 2003 il est rasé
franchement je vois des parties de corps
ni assez impressionnant il est rasé dans
des bunkers et des fantastiques non
visible le défaut et si sûr en plus j'ai
des positions complètement insipide
genre il jouait des trucs franchement
contre le mans il aurait du mal à gagner
certaines je te jure mais will et sebo
connais pas mais ils rasé dans les
positions les plus insipides du monde
j'ai envie de cartes avec les blancs ils
envoyaient jeu ces attaques anglais ces
machins bon du coup ça y est j'ai le
groupe de paris se situe la valine lâche
l'info c'est ça n'intéresse paris avec
naples liverpool l'étoile rouge de
belgrade auquel étoiles où j'avais un
grade ils vont raser n'a pu s'en est
même plus fort mais bon ok tu y vas
royal et quoi c'est carlo l'entraîneur
dans ce cas-là automatiquement non mais
naples s'est jamais ok ils sont fin
prêts pour se qualifier quand même mais
bon tout ça y est pas le groupe
la balade de santé l'étoile rouge foncé
plus que cette haine gagner a conclu m
91 final on est comme la bassée - de
faim alors monaco sur la cat et tico
madrid ils sont avec borussia dortmund
ou lala et bruges
peut-être qu'ils prennent directement en
europa league enfin si ces singes du
film 2d mais oui c'est lui-même monaco
car en plus et à partager groupe à 6
piles à tintin groupe lokomotiv moscou
fc porto celle que nous de finir
galatasaray
non mr gay fatwa le faubourg de paris
c'est autre chose
et parce que tu allais groupe georges
jouvin chester united valence young boys
de berne
allegri boys ils sont parallèles et les
voiliers moins vrai saint-etienne
d'ailleurs non non non c'est intéressant
et n'évoque pas recruter non tenues
et je vais à paris par contre oui paris
je crois que c'était le havre avant il
ne fait bordeaux un peu le groupe fc le
mont de lyon vous saurez que manchester
city le shakhtar et hoffenheim
ok on se demande où d'autre part ici
c'est le plus choquant quand même pas
les dépasser on y trouve encore plus
chaud c'est le goût du barça barça
tottenham eindhoven terminaux ou l'afld
ouais mais l'inter ce fut ce que c'était
oui mais et eindhoven non plus ouais
mais beaucoup toi enter est ce que c'est
vraiment moins fort mais non non mais si
si si si tôt naples c'est fort non mais
naples le problème c'est que quand tu
vas aller jouer en ligue des champions
contre naples
talât dans l'histoire quand même oui et
puis tottenham et tottenham liverpool
c'est pareil en fait de liverpool
beaucoup plus fort que tottenham battu
c'est que les mecs ne marcheront pas
sale jamais ne seront jamais seul bon
revenons à nos moutons
c'est des moutons qu'on regarde jouer
twitter ouais bah merde merde mais du
coup visite est plus intéressant parce
qu'il ya plus attendre sur sa tête vous
amène à un avis mais n'y a pas moins
mais de meilleure qualité on sait pas
ouais salaire du cheveux épais non mais
elle remarque visite aussi ça la rep et
c'est très dangereux en fait qu'un match
pour les joueurs ça explique pourquoi
amène se laisse pousser la barbe
mais je comprenais pas depuis tout à
l'heure c'est de faire un tour à leurs
intérêts du match à jouer et pas l'enjeu
tu vois je me dis tiens ce sont des
moutons quoi bon parfois c'est quand je
sais mais je vais te défoncer tout rejet
de fer h 5 g de faire acheter à faire
chez ces deux chars cachés kg 4 mais tu
me connais par coeur mon fab
ah c'est beau quand même si on a un
cerveau on se tue en serait quand même
tellement au dessus du game quoi mais
dreyer des toiles mon cerveau
le temps en fait que c'est y pas que les
cités deux marques mais nous on joue en
équipe nous sommes des mains à merde on
aperçoit et demain si aujourd'hui le
tournoi et puis merde on va encore plus
mal qu'en fin bref ces pages 5 allait
enfin h5 est un jeu qui avaient décalé
c'est notre seul plan femmes tf1 peut
marine et marine et c'est surtout le
poisson après bâle a du coup h5 m'est
venue il priait fracas et j'ai cinq ans
mais pourquoi pas ben c'est pas pour les
fortes oppositions et la gamme pris
l'ascendant vie des tribus pour mort en
danger visite chez est d'ailleurs son
pseudo au cas où ils peuvent cinq verges
et cinq
je reste convaincu fable c'était mieux
de faire h5 ce que la fois ci cela casse
g5 au final qui vient dessus je te
prends alors que la casse g4 qui a été
sur blanc et tu as une visée plus
suspense
après j'ai sûrement tort bon mais parce
que je veux vous mettre au parfum il
veut qu'on t'a 30 secondes tu apprends
décision malgré qu'il n'ait pas de
marteau fab du temps à la comprendre non
ouais ben elle était belle c'est mon
père une fois qui m'a sorti ça j'étais
mort d'un c'est ce qui me sort une fois
on discute d'un truc mais pendant assez
longtemps peut-être pendant 20 minutes
tu vois on débat et on ne ment et il me
dit j'ai tort et je vais te le prouver
ok je dis ok mais c'est bizarre fait sur
les débats comme ça oui
et en fait il ça le dvd de torque
ne cherchez quoi ces voix-là georges
toutefois 13 ses fils et ses magnifiques
commune faire comme s'il n'y a pas une
seconde quand même l a pas fait h5 érigé
cap donc forcément c'est important pour
pour avesnes orbite un score que parce
que là il a rappelé à perdre c'est même
un bond de la maison final sa famille
veut équilibrer le truc basse assez
confiant pour avesnes fable à seynod une
petite italienne prince pour revivre la
vie il faut si c'était pas une idée de
la nva elle ça serait que je remette le
fond en bessin quant à quelques rallier
et ses jeux avec des caches vie et
moeurs sur à 6,5
cette occasion les rechanges
il a été faussé par des amendes le
processus devait prendre mais l'effet
était super bien au final c'est quand
même pas avec qui
leur visite en russie ça veut dire voir
tu vois ça
perso j'ai encore envie d'envoyer 17 à 6
d'amd cet ouvrage 3 outillage match part
peut-être la foux proches croient direct
je pense que je vais prendre ça devrait
vous êtes les plus sains d'esprit non tu
crois toujours clamé la victoire
ça c'est fort ça si tu faire des coups
et si pourri auquel halte à son idée là
dessus a été dire qu'ils avaient faim
maintenant kf4 et a plus faim voilà tu
pour moi mais bon même et fab
peut-être qu'on va faire dame 17 après
bon là on boucle va là tu veux pas
l'assurance tu bouffes ans en d3 quand
même et tu
mais c'est bien joué dès 5 ans premier
il n'a pas le temps de faire foi f1 pour
le moment ouais je crois ce choix
clairement je ne peux expliquer
l'ensemble à moitié l'agencé qui veut
faire menaces menace menace menacer
prendre au dernier moment
l'incendié menace tout cela tu menaces
aux cinq sont pas laxistes d'un bref si
c'est une fois qu'elle est proche 3 ok
tu t'en sors pape dont les havanes faut
jouer autre chose que ses positions
étaient bonnes et clément tout le temps
je pense que j'avais ni les moins en
stratégie manière d'être calme - voorn
en france contre les italiens avons sur
ce qu'on voit là les citadines avec les
ventes se passent mal la première est
organisée bien défoncé mais après c'est
plus passer pareille
malheureusement
blais à se rendre si on prend 1,5 à se
prendre qu'à elle prend h3 il est
peut-être le x 7 il peut se réveiller un
jour il est vraiment très mal peut-être
bouffant fkt faire flouer f
comme ça si on prend au sein qui peut
reprendre du cavalier mais bon tu vas
être mal mais je ne peux pas m me blanc
peut donc l'otan doivent une fois
retrouvé la moindre mal
bah non mais il est en train de se faire
et vite disais quoi mais vie dit vas-y
l'air tellement tellement confiant on
sent qu'il est plus fort en fait bien
son attitude
ouais bon on prend ce que l'autre veut
tenter le zazen de tenter du fou g5 a
lieu cinq gp enfin le sac de même sa
toile qui a eu cinq heures d'un
incroyable 2 alors j'en sais rien mangé
bien bu cela on me l'a souvent h3
d'ailleurs peut-être d'un fc 3 h2k et
rouages de têtu tu prépares un peu
cavalier ou cinq noms ya quelques
bonbons peut-être peut-être h6 tu t'en
fous tu ailles à plouvien plus fou 4
blanche
tu peux tu affaiblir l'otan n'a rien à
faire quand tu pars coup d'oeil à 8,6 et
500 villes et 6 e laurent blanc 7
il y aura un v8 ouais ouais mais ce que
j'allais dire femme femme femme bafouée
8 après c'est pas bien pour la danse bon
après on va s'accrocher la partie
d'avant il n'était pas très bien il y
avait la gagne et qui est un petit peu
au final annonçant des qualités depuis
dont on sent la pugnace it et non
maintien ces cas là dieu tu sens la
pugnacité 0 ouais pugnace mans
d'un chrono un truc ouais j'ai un chrono
il ya 18 minutes j'ai le chrono officiel
femme parce que c'est que ça
jasmin de bouteilles de vin voire gens
non armés ils sont réellement fou en
fait un bien fou dans le chat j'ai
compagne il y en a pas beaucoup qui
écrivent d'ailleurs je sais pas je sais
pas pourquoi ils sont pas actifs c'était
beaucoup plus actif en la semaine que
phil caps et est partout
[Musique]
mais
mais ils sont complètement fous non mais
pas téméraire des joueurs des joueurs
doivent passer qui boit de l'eau malte
est voilé du gange
mais c'est dangereux bien infiltré comme
el pueblo sais pas où ils habitent des
rhinites ce qui l'habite en inde
on ne sait pas mais je pense qu'il met
en mode c'est qu'il ya eu le mariage n'y
a pas longtemps de drouot à paris qu'à
bricolage aux ouais mais bon j'aime sur
facebook à lille c'est très heureux
quand ils ont fait un article machin
hyper long avec les photos du mariage et
ils sont super contents qu'elle se
marier avec chandra je crois que ma
chance je sais pas s'il a un rapport
avec les échecs en fait je suis moi il
ya un grand match en moins oui mais
alors est-ce que c'est le grand maître
chandra ou est ce que ça nous attendre à
tuer je ne suis pas les regarder en fait
c'était le même champ draps sur nos lits
sûrement que si oui mais toi je veux pas
d informer les gens j'en sais rien en
fait bref cette recette satisfait tous
réussissent et tours 2-2 et tourer et
ouais je le doublais j'aurai une tour
bon alors il va gérer cette petite
finale parce que l'heure a fait de la
merde fabrique j'avais envie de faire du
tour à 5 tours b 5 vous ne savez pas de
même bien loin
il va quand même faire parce que
peut-être le nez s'il fait tomber quatre
après sa tête revenir donc enfin retour
des deux s'est plus passé deux tours
c'est qu'il ya très tu te contours
d'anciennes études à trois mois est
tombé 5 tours b 3 tours des trois non
bah j'aime pas du doigt 3 300 mètres
assez dégueu comme coûtant du fixe ou
des pions sur 15 morts fait des trous de
130 nul quoi à 3,8
original le zazen il est éclairé la vie
dit il est écoeuré s'il perd son pion
quoi aller là bas est très heureux quoi
il a fait un petit geste tu vois de la
tête
je regarde way l'idée c'est qu'ils
patron maintenant tu vas tu sens qu'il
est tu vois ça va être très qui on le
voit
ah bah c'est pas forcément les échecs de
magnus après non je veux mais contre
magnus pareil ficam petrosyan collège
fait un très mauvais match je n'ai je
n'ai gagné que voir à 2 je peux le
second tour - l'armée contre manière
aucune chance avec ce style mais contre
tous en fait tu aimais cariat qui est du
welt ménaka famille
non cette bonne chance zarif c'est leur
verse contre toi il est favori mais bon
on va pas refaire comme attention pour
visite pas ce qu'il va se passer pas mal
de chance il ne faudra pas les regretter
à la fin parce que je sais pas
s'améliorer pour lui avec les cadences
plus courte
après il joue plus vite quand même bons
à 6 nuls commence enfin il vient de
comme dirait vlad de pousser une galerie
les écuries de son coup là auquel il
pensait avoir g3 et la rate et tourcoing
f3 non mais tu assistes quoi des grands
tours profonde et capté change tout bus
essayer c'est juste c'est nul
quand en plus vous allez va la perdre
bah ouais je sais ce qu'ils valent à
regretter ces jeunes journalistes qui
tournent leur veste n'avait là c'est
comme ça c'est grave le coup j'arrive à
prendre prendre un enfant de 8 ans
devenue la place il fait ça quoi mais il
a pensé qu'il avait g3 c'est sûr ils
voulaient peut-être même essayer de la
gagner j'en sais rien
sûrement heureux peu trop ambitieux
défaut
après ce dur de reprocher bas mais bon
si tu peux gagner face il y avait là
vont clairement tu pouvais pas quoi
c'est déjà beau de faire nul si on vient
demander au sortir de l'ouverture non
mais clairement mais bon j'aime pas trop
reprocher aux joueurs leur combativité
leur zeller excès de tu sais je remarque
enfin quand je joue par exemple qui est
un peu ce défaut
je remarque enfin le défaut d'être pas
assez ambitieux enfin j'avais se
défoulent en tout cas je remarque que
quand je suis plus ambitieux qui est des
fois je le perds aussi comme un idiot
comme ça mais d'un point de vue général
je joue mieux en fait j'en parle avec le
mindset au début de la partie de thua de
vouloir gagner à tout prix
ça me réussit mieux alors évidemment et
des parties de superbes comme ça
bêtement mais du coup si tu regardes le
scénario des partis en entier tu
comprendras que gassama mieux réussies
jouer agressif tout le temps et leur
fils ya peut-être là tenir ce que fait
surprendre g7 et 5 et pousser tout à
fond et le roi va être loin de tout et
rêvent sites comme the dome
belle côte en finale cimpor va voir mais
moi c'est chiant je vois pas là pour une
tournée la tour h3c mais avant est ce
qu'il peut prendre les tours j'ai gardé
d'autres non mais l'internaute mais
j'avoue être essayés tour g4 cooder
naturellement aussi mais sait-on jamais
philidor fieldwork était un grand maître
en force rires enfin pas un risque il
est évident qu'elle titre de grand
maître a posteriori d'ailleurs pas fini
d'en baver cocon du car des joueurs
qu'ils ont eu un peu marre auxi par
exemple il y en a plein en fait qu'il en
eût il le méritera en tout cas mais
c'est un joueur français qui a théorisé
la fina convient de voir celle là
deltour fou contre tours il a fait des
trucs pour la l'ouverture à la défense
philidor soutien de son nom évidemment
ya fait il des compositeurs musique
aussi franchement tu veux mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est plus
connu pour ses compositions musicales
d'ailleurs pas par nous mais oui peut
être non pas des gens de chance qui de
part sa bonne question fois le faire un
sondage pour un micro trottoir un de ces
quatre est-ce qu'il n'est pas en train
de tenter un genre de méthode ruiz peut
on aimer g4g 2 grid quoi m et fab est ce
que en tentant une grise comme ça
surtout à ce point comme devant mille
spectateurs français est ce que c'est
parce que tout le monde adorait
est ce que c'est vraiment autorisé là il
ya une yahya yahya m haies femmes
je pense que je devais aucune chance au
nord dévasté par la méthode ruiz tak tak
surprise ça fait mal ah oui les cas où
il est ko debout les cows mais ben
willacy ok ils essayent de se mettre des
pions formation ruiz aussi au centre
enfin fou
un bijou la théorie officielle deux
échecs mais il va se prendre de
l'antijeu central tout ça monsieur les
bisous ce qui tient à trois femmes elle
est bon là c'est ce qui va faire rod pas
tout de suite je donne [ __ ] pourquoi
pas bougé de là les voilà tout est en
place afin d'être après re de dames j'ai
un tour f1 roi des rois c'est un mois
pour faire un coup d'attentes voilà
mesdames au travers également le nom de
l'adresse du roi adverse et puis tu qui
va être très conventionnel comme un coût
inférieur à des bretons de quasi absent
quatre à y fait la moue il fait l'amour
ces cas là il fait ils sont fous j'ai
deux noms très bien pour prendre les six
bagues ou d'autres petits roth va devoir
se résoudre tel coupe conventionnelle
farah mais pourquoi potes des 4
attends pourquoi on prend proie fait pas
ce g5 et on bouffe des cinq potes tu vas
faire bonus il prend d'abord bon ok
prendre du coup j'imagine qu'à l'époque
clark et ses quatre peut-être prend des
5 et bessines se remette en place parce
que là les pouvoirs bien il faut juste
natas fort ok maintenant maintenant qui
rentre d'irak où on se place du petit
tour c'est un non mais ça va être celui
là ça ressemble à une sorte de sylviane
finck dans des squats qui s'est passé
pour moi ça ressemble à une ruine
saharien d'employer des mots savants
famille pour excuse moi de te le dire
j'adore comme l'a dit cette excuse moi
de te le dire ton pays tu vas te le dire
quand même pas méchant mais c'est ce que
ce qu'ils avaient envie médias en fait
quand il dit excuse moi de te le dire il
va dire un truc complètement en finlande
a tout autant un truc sympa si on lui
dit inquiet mauricien est quand même pas
mal sorti il va lutter contre par fatal
la us open dans 30 minutes y'a rogers
qui rentre sur le court face à bollaërt
bon père un bon reçu grâce à quoi
comptant sur eurosport je vais pas
m'abonner toutes les chaînes de sport
donc les camps mais j'ai abandonné je
suis écoeuré moi je suis écoeuré par les
chaînes télé j'ai déjà billy 90 à rmc
machin à canal plus ou moins en moins de
choses et on bientôt disparaître
mais ok ce jour là quand même temps
ouais bon bein c'était bien pour moi un
moment donné nous avons chez chaffoteaux
des claques et 150 euros par mois si tu
veux vraiment pouvoir cet intéressant
ouais tu sais que tu sais que rien que
bin canale truc sport et où j'ai regardé
je voulais peut-être m'abonner mais
c'est 600 euros par an par le tas
devrait pas lui échapper
enfin ça c'est juste que si je peux à
600 euros par an je vais avoir
absolument tout ben on est en fait ce
qui m'énerve encore plus c'est que
voulait acheter juste le top 14 un peu
comme ils font aux états unis avec la
nfl ajnfl tâche et toute la nfl pour 180
dollars par an france n'ont surtout
prendre ce quatuor la ligue des
champions je regarde pas donc ça
m'embête un peu de prendre canal et bim
sport ce que j'ai besoin des deux pour
voir là le top 14 et la coupe d'europe
de rugby et les matches de nos
fournisseurs où il a peut-être ça le
super duke a mais en fait le problème
c'est que c'est que je dois acheter tout
fait obama fait que plus sauf si tu
prends un bar sympa tu diffuses des
trucs tu va me motiver mais faut que ça
existe ouais mais bon ça médias bien
quoi mais moi j'adore
on parle tout le temps non mais bon bout
d'un moment il ya aussi un moment où ça
devient ça devient trop cher pour face à
deux j'aime pas quoi non mais là c'est
n'importe quoi pas sérieux ça mais en
fait j'avais le premier quelques années
mais c'était vraiment cher à l'époque de
foot + on pouvait voir un lien oui
c'était il ya quoi il ya huit ans de sa
note et je payais de plus ou moins 4
euros par mois
mais après c'est calme et bean mais là
ça repart dans les mêmes tarifs
ce que c'est exagéré meilleur c'est
clair les échecs c'est complètement
gratuit pour autant quand même pas
beaucoup de monde qui regarde tu as des
fois ça me ça m'attriste un peu quand
même un bon après vers même nous quoi on
va plus regarder
j'aurais bien un match de foot un match
de tennis une partie entière c'est bon
ça voilà ça dépend non ses dépenses et
la coupe du monde être comme ça on était
content l'hyper chaud mais par des
partis des tournois souvent faut
s'accrocher pas pour tout de suite
passionné tout le long les mecs ce jour
28 fois par an mais c'est ça mais en
fait non mais en fait si au foot c'était
tu avais tu avais saint-etienne psg
saint-etienne monaco saint-etienne lyon
et qu'il joue et s'ils font ensemble
parents et que c'était que ces six
équipes là qu'ils jouent ensemble tu es
tu regarderas être plus non plus un neuf
possibles marc c'est pas ce pas le vin
pas le jeu d'échecs le problème c'est un
beau jeu imagine que les matchs comment
sont organisés les qui fait des trucs
faire une syncope de faire un règlement
faire un départage par moments se dit ok
là mais il est des millions et des
millions c'était 82,2 de règlement des
idiots produire d'autres non mais
imagine que les matchs ils durent six
heures à chaque fois que ce soit
toujours les mêmes équipes qui jouent en
fait je regarderai plus non plus
non mais imagine que tu vois mes mecs
même un lion synthé qu'un derby imagine
le match commence à 14h et finit à 21h
et genre ton n'a pas deux parentes on
attend la douce mais et c'est tous les
ans comme ça et c'est tout le temps les
mêmes joueurs ça perd sa saveur
l'émission au bout d'un moment tu as
juste pu regarder enfin paraîtrait de
regarder n'importe quel sport en fait
c'est juste normal mais le tennis au
site a rétréci et rogers nadal c'est en
dix huit sets gagnants du set gagnant
qui joue que très peu joué qu'une
quarantaine de fois dans leur vie quoi
c'est un grand classique mais aux échecs
le grand classique ses quarante fois
dans l'année que j'exagère un poil
sommes bien comme on lui servait une
coupe de foot par an une coupe du monde
de foot par an on arrêterait aussi un la
rareté donne de l'intérêt
ouais c'est pour ça que c'est pas mal de
ce format des speechs est ce que
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient des joueurs
un peu moins forts comme ça ça permet de
voir d'autres choses comme on fait
maintenant ça permet de voir se faire
massacrer par des mecs plus fort et puis
finalement le nak accarias keane ou quoi
on va même pas la voir toutes les
saisons tu vois on va avoir une saison
sur deux là le mv ariana cas c'est un
classique ça va être la troisième fois
mais tu vois en 403 3 saisons c'est
troisième fois il avait fait ses
deuxième fois en trois saisons qui se
jouent ensemble dans le web dans le truc
parce qu avant c mais déjà on n'a jamais
eu de même vu comme ça non non non mon
speech
non on n'a jamais mais c'est bien ça du
coup oui dans mes supports au crédit
mais j'étais voilà donc jour ça arrive
tu vas te dire oui rose smallwood douze
fois par an non mais montera en fait on
sera super chaud quand tu auras karl
scène mdl en speech est ce parce qu'on
n'a jamais vu et je suis curieux de voir
mes serviettes la rareté c'est ça
apporte quelque chose
ben on a fait des jo qu'aux gens finale
à séoul john wells mais ça faisait trois
ans que c'était pas jouer nadal
ils sont pas joué depuis depuis plus
d'un an non mais c'est donc que c'est un
événement pas tout à fait car nadal tu
étais hyper heureux de matchcraft aime
le tennis c'est une opposition de style
machin et de propos paraissent et c'est
toujours des gros matches à un génial
mais bien sûr si tu vois chaque semaine
se jouer à monte déjà à roland garros
jouer chaque finale chaque année shy'm à
coûter cher c'est une fois par an mais
c'est chiant mais ouais c'était chiant
juste tourner le match mais on a des
gens se plaint de voir le match une fois
par an alors imagine
il se joue à louvain paris un machin est
bien within se joue pas une fois alloue
un panneau sur trois fautes puisse
rejouer trois fois les mêmes
appartiendront mais après m'être
forcément taplin deux nuls c'est les
mecs n'ont plus dé faire surprise il se
joue qu'à soi les ouvertures et les ma
faim en fait tu appauvri en plus le foot
que le fait que ce soit moi regarder
pour le public qui va les mecs ils sont
trop l'habitude de jouer quoi
ouais énervé c'est sûr mais d'ailleurs
au tennis tu vois quand c'est des
matches entre
alors qu'ils se connaissent très bien
les matchs sur son non moins
spectaculaire quant à des matchs le
joueur qui s'entraîne souvent ensemble
comme un match entre français mais mec
qui sait bien et tout va pour l emploi
de dm bien tu sais que tu voies entre
guillemets rendre l'auto triste mathieu
je suis de lui faire mal que pour gagner
un match
et des fois juste pour nous faire ça un
ami bon c'est le score après mais il y
en a qui arrive puisque d'autres briques
et 6 répétition qua non mais je sais pas
je pense qu'il va essayer de la gagner
quand même visite parce qu'il a les fous
en fins et fatah camus à la perte de foo
fighters la basse et les fous risque
iver usi fier quoi avait évoqué vous qui
je veux un peu vite
c'est après une spéciale à faire et pour
mon genre de position les cavaliers 102
sous la main mais c'est assez étonnant
qu'il faudrait qu'on trouve des
rondavelles adhère au départ et non mais
j'en regarde la partie 2-2 une nouvelle
coupe mc à cette année thank you fields
est viré ouais vous remonte en fait à la
fontaine très bien pour les blancs c'est
à la paire de foot a fixé les pions ans
et 6 baies sata 6 est à tout cas ce
blanche paul et noir donc fait il a eu
aucun mal à faire nul même limite c'est
lui après qui est un peu mieux enfin bon
c'est juste une c'est pourquoi opposer
mais tu vois ce jeudi du bon côté des
trucs et aux québécois comment expliquer
ça est un peu je vois très souvent gris
karo kann août à la paire de phu quy
saharien top kill en d5 qui est chiant
damballa dans ce parti là etc
mais là je la trouve qu'elle est une des
versions idéal mais en fait moi j'avais
eu une règle c'est que dans les
pollutions semi ouverte si lecavalier a
un socle centrale il compense le fouet
mais il faut qu'il a un sac le central
way back on est là c'est six mois oui
exact mais ouais tu veux 4
mais mes hockey dreams vais les îles
avec un habit ces contrats bêtement à
bcf ghg chaque côté donc tu peu comme
essayer de déloger mais sa mère
s'appelle tout marché enfin je sais pas
en tout cas dans les trucs classiques
quand tu es vieux bouquins soviétique et
où c'est ce qui est écrit en fait
position ferme et cavaliers plus fort qu
ils sont ouvertes fou plus fort et
position semi ouverte six cavaliers 5 le
central égal d'après moi je te dis ce
que j'ai lu un prétoire des pages
je le comprends consentis mais la pythie
venger quand même tu as voudra jouer
pour trouver avec les blancs qu'on va
pas jouer avec la peur de tout le temps
je vois que ça suffit pas tu n'es pas
soviétique je comprends le truc avec
espoir mais en fait je pense à un truc
hyper important à comprendre parce que
c'est un peu contre intuitif balle
du coup fab c'est la pause la fin ça va
repartir
donc à la surprise générale quand même
faut le dire ça mais n'a gagné 1,20
contre le cours du jeu par la surprise
générale contre le cours du jeu via il
est vite à cette occasion ses principaux
une partie comme ethernet 2 2 et voilà
vous écoute non mais j'ai envie de te
dire life is life life is life like
these comment il faudra chanter l'amour
tu as le travail qu'on vire tu as chanté
sans connecter parole lee chang
l'éthique a réalisé un truc fantastique
on faisait ce matin m
but my father is chanter comme ça en
fait c'était génial s'il connaissait bat
my father l'april ne savais plus quoi du
bus des summer time of my father effet
après bon bah on se plaint nana na na va
chasser mais ils essaient dire un mot
quand même quoi il avait sa et son plus
grand classique c'était bien sûr sa
reprise de what a wonderful world
une reprise mythique de cette chanson je
joue mon rôle c'est fantastique
les cover de mur tu as ça ça aurait plus
6 6 6 à 15 ans il en était déjà à
l'époque de youtube à fond là il 15 20
ans
myrtal site aurait fait des cover
c'était dans le film est assez c'était
fini coiffe en champagne le youtube game
n'existait plus tu vois c'était mieux
rtas quoi on passe au dessus de tout
l'armée tout en dessus de tout et c'est
fantastique comme que mur face a fini
son entraîneur des jeunes de réussir je
vois ton article sur chandra vaches
l'article tutoriel genre très clair
là-dessus mais parce qu'il est invité au
mariage magnano alors là du coup les
photos attention qu'on rend fou les
photos sont au dessus de tout comme un
fou photographe professionnel
je vais me en caméra on te voit je fais
un signe de l'art alain du coup je ne
sais pas s'il y aura des articles non
mais c'est un beau mariage c'est un beau
mariage mobilise là je vois les photos
sur rien et qui s'attaque à un bouquin
les nouveautés mamoghli doit être maître
josé chaque colonne chandra moi je
l'appelle championnat a personnellement
mais mais il n'a pas écrit gm à côté de
son nom du coup il fallait alors que
pourrait lui donc je me dis peut-être
que non en fait qu'est-ce détonnant je
sais pas je sais pas je naviguais ça va
être un grand spectacle ce mariage ou
pas mais je suis très déçu de paille a
trahi mais après pour te dire la vérité
j suis pas allé ce que j'étais pas
invitée en fait même boucle là sinon
c'était peut-être aller m'acheter prime
time pour un match comme ça quand même
ça reprend alors dans des bruits de
coups et les prix de coûts des prix de
pouls du coup tu m'as fait peur
italienne moi quand même il arrivait à
résister à la grise
c'est impressionnant que peut-être il
mérite mieux l'avantagé d'un point que
pour cet exploit quoi possible possible
fable mais mais je crois que c'était une
bonne voix pour et 9
j'aime mieux les noms je sais pas
construit qui ça va jouer en demie cette
histoire là on ira voir après et il est
au programme un d'accord en car je veux
dire mais je pense qu'en quarts
c'est dur ça va être un peu légère ils
sont dans le quart de tableau le plus
faible par contre je crois qu'on peut te
prendrais ac cardiaque c'est gris chat
c'est quoi le froid qui sont dans le car
en bas à droite dans le calme à à droite
c'est peut-être ma mais c'est pas contre
aarau jeu vaudra bien le maître qui pose
de grilles attentats et elle n'a qu'à
nvn naka grisha car y'a qu'ça je sais
mauvaise note en bas à gauche on botte
en bas à gauche tu as aronian qui s'est
qualifié il faut que ce combat mais en
fait c'est une idée horrible ses côtés
ouais en fait part à droite ce qui le
fera beaucoup ta vie toyota va voir ça
et tu vas voir qu'ils ont fait
maintenant on va commenter tous les
matches donc on devrait ça à oui c'est
dommage qu'on a ratées why i saw mais
bon c'est pas les plus forts ouais mais
contre ce aussi un pelage
regarde là il peut arriver là sans un
regard vers une pièce mais même sort
mais ducousso en demi finale contre le
vainqueur de grisha cardiaque si c'est
gris charbon tout peut arriver
john cardiaque c'est même pas la peine
qu'ils viennent de spawn des connexions
mais je suis d'accord avec rennes chien
qui dit daniel navrot dit ce qui tua il
aimerait bien le voir
bah oui je me souviens mais bon après on
voit bien et noir je pense qu'il doit
passer des qualifs pas pourquoi on dit
ce qui et pas parce qu'un quand m
confuse de vue pas georges alors alors
alors lien d'arguments il a gagné le
streamer championship c'est ben oui mais
les mecs ils font pas forcément du
stress vous vous moquez du sud
américains et les personnes
je ne crois pas ils sont américains ils
peuvent faire et et moi ça me dosé papa
qui joue même mais j'aime bien moi que
les trucs sont méritants j'ai rempli un
peu parce que le mec a gagné 1 mais il a
quand même gagné une compétition de
chasse car ou quoi oui j'écoute chasse
car ils veulent un peu tirer la
couverture alors qu'on peut
aussi non mais ils font ce qu'ils
veulent de leur événement mais non mais
je ne sais pas assez de toi qualifiés
pour des qualifs comme cette année le
meilleur l'était amr est toi qui
s'assoiront match entre eux et que s'il
le gagne ok tu y es genre très longtemps
on te laisse faire ça mais complète
d'office va les voir tous ces deux
femmes et faut prendre les trois ans je
vois mal de finir on a perdu bêtement
non mais on verra bien mais en tout cas
c'est pas délirant d'avoir failli
en plus on a vu j'étais bon en bibitte
city bond du let est il que deux chiens
comme si je vais très vite pas mal alors
après vous être gagnée dans un niveau
énorme avec l'élite depuis vingt mois
après après après ce qui plaide aussi en
sa faveur c'est que cette année quand
ils ont fait les qualifs
bon c'est dominguez qui s'est qualifié
donc ça c'était bien mais mais il a
quand même dans les arénas bon vu que
c'est là qu'on peut comparer puisqu'ils
avaient hammer et meilleurs qu'ils
étaient des deux côtés des qualifs et en
scène suit des trois autres on était
là-bas et il est vraiment beaucoup plus
fort que meilleure mamelle que nous y
sommes
ok dans les joueurs qui jouent pas le
speech la bayanne à blâmer c'est young
david leur a peut-être patrick ewing co2
alors tu as peut-être qu'ils ont refusé
aussi faim parce que
oui mais les enquêtes apostats secteur
rapporte on a vu l'an dernier mais bon
on a vu des gens qui souffrent a sonné
quota des neiges du tchad est plein de
chinois qui pourrait faire rire où je me
dis à andré qui n'y il y avait ma
médaille en dégâts andré qui n'a déjà
fait fabrics d'arabie la fob tora des
dunes des anciens comme les causses à
rich les anglais comme owen décembre tu
as tellement de joueurs qui ont plus de
classement lors des scream la journée ce
terrain à l'appel quoi ouais mais note
la cofam une base saine enfin on peut
aller très loin
on peut aller très loin de terre tu vas
très loin et c'est ton droit
non mais ok pas il a le droit de fermer
ta qu'on te dise moi en toi tu joues tu
dévotement alors que tu as 80 ouais mais
après 1 précédemment
après c'est sur invitation regarde quand
tu prends par exemple le grande chaise
tout revoir le grand duché soit après
ils ont leur classement spécifique mais
t'as plein de tournois où c'est pas
sélectionné au vélo non plus hein
non mais tu fais ce que tu attends les
internautes mais l'argent va il suffit
d'effectuer les mecs je suis en contrat
aidé ou on va vous présentons un objet
que les pieds taipei non mais voilà
d'ailleurs c'est tout pas de jouer après
ce serait sympa d'ailleurs ben même
dextérité pédestre déry sinon il s'est
fait contre attaquer avec le clouage sur
les colonnes d ce génial s'est fait une
partie que vous qui était complètement
insipide et c'est pas clair mais pas
pillé le 5 mai vous étiez peut-être
faire fuir f53 f5 la fab aujourd'hui la
vie pareille mais peut-être oui c'est
pour ça que je vais faire [ __ ] 5
mais bon ça va quand même pas les 1 300
km très mal mais oui face au fn pas bien
de devoir rentrer à duarte une pièce de
plus pour rien
mais quel génie quand ils s'en foutent
je continue à jouer c'est que c'est que
sa pièce devant elle car l'activité mais
va-t-il va devoir sûrement fier de
pièces pour la tour il y aura une
qualité une qualité c'est clair c'est
incroyable ce qu'ils gagnent pas celle
là
[Musique]
c'est extraordinaire je sais pas si le
mot n'y a pas de g4 la neige non mais il
faut que fabre en sueur qua non mais je
comprends pas j'ai comme il est bon on
vous dit quoi les niveaux se prendre soi
qu'est ce que c'est que cette partie je
comprends rien mais trois bref trois en
fait cette façon d'agir ouvrages de
droit j'ai trois tu sortais deviendrait
une partie de l'abonnement auprès des
parties pédagogique machin on peut voir
deux jours entre eux 63e ça va mais là
c'est vrai que le niveau de la partie là
l'enchaînement c'est l'armistice ans
maximum maximum et encore je suis
peut-être pas gentil pour les 1600 mais
bon on doit peut-être la fatigue il ya
non meilleur des trucs des grands
maîtres comme ça ils sont plus forts que
moi comme je vais je pas besoin de dire
huîtres nul mais la nature du multicast
l'ordi fab comprend narrer peut-être que
visite chez pas ils s'attendent à ce
qu'il abandonne icd concentré il n'a pas
réussi à ce nom mais il y à perdre et on
va on a tous déjà fait des gaves
répression gagner on trie pas tout ça
mais mes toiles l'enchaînement de l'ain
puis de l'autre méchant bien il va la
perdre non mais c'est pas perdants mais
je sens qu'il va la perdre il a fallu la
tombe et où il va lui arriver une merde
oh [ __ ] ça j'ai jamais vue de ma vie
encore non mais la partie je pense et
niveau 14 ans est parti savez vous
commentez les quais c'est peut-être
l'équipe honda parti de bosses qua non
mais c'est je pense que c'est la pire
partie de ce kit chasse de l'histoire du
speech s y en a pas tout vu mais ce
qu'on a vu bref ensemble d'un messager
jamais jamais vu encore les bons un pote
pour
bonbons incroyable incroyable incroyable
bon du coup non mais surtout qu'on
invite le fou juste à côté
y'a rien à voir qu'à 15 secondes contre
3 incroyable incroyable parce qu'on
vient de dire bob you would technique
welcome pack pour montrer quoi voilà
c'est parfois quoi c'était ben y'a pas
de mots non mais des jardins de séance
de tirs au but où il a formé train là
est juste ça me fait marrer parce que
j'ai vu un best-of pierre derenne ch les
pires gaffes qu'il a commenté en direct
ouais est ok il ya eu une guerre par
exemple de kamski qui fait une super
finale technique qui à un moment donné
l'autre il alors en f4 il joue droit je
crois h4 il sera en battant na waie vous
mettez les au frais ok mais c'est une
erreur mais là je sais pas c'était il ya
peut être eu quatre ou cinq gaffe de
pièces en a à chaque fois c'était jean
abboud au cou maxi quand même c'était
des tactiques très simple il ya le front
faire mieux nous l'apporté que ceux ci
il ya il ya le flou après avec les g4
qui a prêté une finale tu as gagné que
vous allez tour tu peux faire technique
bon tu te fais est nul en force après
donne ta tour m'arrêter mais c'est vrai
je n'ai pas fini par un pacte quand même
baisse de 19,9 raté juste le bon groupe
mais vie dit-il smara mais très heureux
je pense la même patinoire enfin tant
mieux non mais je jouais comme ça je ne
lâcherai hyper énervé après moins que je
casserai tout cas je ne suis plus jouer
c'est plus possible quoi là tu imagines
vlad s'ils jouent comme ça non mais oui
ah ben là je pense que c'est ça fait ça
finit dans les faits divers il va te
dire combien je dois boire pour jouer
comme ça que je pense que même s'ils
jouent comme ça a complètement bourré il
est très déçu de lui quoi si oui la
vodka et est frelaté
[Rires]
en fait il a déjà sorti il m'a déjà dit
ça en fait oui c'était la qualité de la
vodka c'est surtout pas la quantité la
quantité farm la cua c'était normal
c'est une très mauvaise qualité quel
génie se flatte bon du coup on vient le
mouton encore ou pas bah oui ce serait
même la même ouverture malheureusement
voyez c'est un peu comme un haut niveau
en fait au bout d'un moment c'est les
mêmes joueurs sur qui reviennent quand
ces deux joueurs qui s'affrontent et ça
explique se sont parlés vous mia
nuisibles jovial et très heureux quoi ça
parle duo de 1400 des lots mais au lieu
de vous [ __ ] bêtement de leur gueule
contentez vous de rester dans l'analyse
qu il reste mondial répondra pas été
méchant ce n'est pas pourtant barre toi
voilà la majorité sont très heureux que
la répartie boom dégâts photo banon mais
j'avoue que je n'ai jamais changé bien
spécifié que les mecs des grands maîtres
plus fort que moi à quoi tient pas
content de moi tim page ça veut dire
c'est pas toi tu peux écouter ce qu'on
dit aussi qu elle est pas offusqué sûr
s'il a fait pleurer de rire
c'était tellement beau fab
non mais en fait je déteste quand des
pseudo je ne te dire des trucs comme ça
quoi
admettons vrai nom est ok on parle
italien sur quoi j'ai envie de dire
bravo femmes actifs
tu as tout donné quoi noms évoqués
pour comprendre au chat non plus loin
dans ma vie dit tout calmez vous aussi
kouadio qui dit fabien qui va le dessus
montrent égard du maroc
rdv un ver dans dix ou si oui est ce que
tu es le mec qui fait des tracks qui
peut me faire avoir de talent fou rire
en life pas sérieux c'était fou c'était
beau quoi je crois qu'il y revient au
même
alors ce fait ce à quoi bon après je me
sens frais d'entraînement quoi dans la
montagne et tout j'espère tu vas pas le
croiser à orly au retour soit c'était ça
devenait tellement du coeur quoi je
crois qu'il a mené un raid de nom mais
le truc c'est je ne cherchais pas je
crois pas qu on était méchant et si on
l'a été ce n'est pas le but mais je
pense qu'il a très bien pris après
musique jovial crois que ça me fait
marrer aussi je crois qu'il a très bien
pris et qu'il est dans le délire donc en
fait il va j'ai envie de dire bravo
qu'enfin fou il le prend bien donc c'est
pourquoi donc c'est bon donc non mais tu
as i les sports il est cependant le dire
au revoir une bière ensemble un de ces
quatre je crois que ça le fait marrer au
contraire c'est la naissance d'une bonne
amie qui est finalement se trouver bien
fait il est dans l'esprit à fond quand
fait qui part j'ai envie de te dire
il est au dessus de tout quoi aussi mais
ça a quand tu vois quand on sait bien
pris et où j'ai envie de te dire c'est
beau quoi bon alors ce qui concerne
lorsque vous avez un caillou visite ce à
quoi les a toujours des 6 un truc comme
ça
bref os3 pas mal je pense se débarrasser
un peu de pièces et sans prendre option
j'ai mis les larmes aux yeux avec ton
truc là enfin même si c'est chaque tour
des huit c'est fini damas six tours des
8 non mais attends un nom arrivé il ya
les fous g7 pardon je me suis sûr autour
d'élus qui avaient touché sept ans à
défendre d'autres tempos nos idées dans
deux films qui jure sur chez ce qui est
moins bien qu'en haïti ce puisque les
plus actifs et peut être aller voilà m
devant la chaîne de plus on voit
sancéens b2 je ne sais pas des choses
comme ça by pour tourner le truc encore
dit qu'il a du mal dans le petit jeu et
c'est très bien de passer un moment
donné qui sacralise et de ses partis ça
a tellement il est parti je suis quand
même c'est pas mal comme comme les trous
son image et non mais j'y vais c'est
pour ça j'ai bien écouté j'ai un peu de
mal dans le petit jeu enfin tu as ton
périmetre voit un petit périmètre est
capable en cas d'excès ce qui est plus
importante pour bien jouer les finales
et dont le petit jeu bailly la table ce
petit jeu et savoir les petites
tactiques des chip tactique et chipeau
quoique que warner quelques titres nul
n'en fait le niveau est assez serré quoi
on sait pas trop qui va gagner ce match
au moins sa vessie mais en fait c'est
important dans les finales de voir des
petites tactiques pour faire marcher ses
idées allaient en fait c'est fantastique
en fait nous ils jouent bien en fait il
parlait pas du tout du tout en fait il
se moquait des mecs étaient 14 ans le
chat en fait
enfin si en fait ces mots là désolé
nuisibles le joli mais l'aide pour
voyager au caire a du coup je suis
excité contre de nappes phréatiques
contre un truc plus tard fois je sais
pas ils furent fait son petit plein avec
damas est qu'on avait bien aimé
ouais mais je cherchais en fait ce plan
sont pas relâcher la plupart on
l'obtenait mais en fait c'est comme ça
mais ok il s'entête avec ce système
deux jeux à 4 ils truquent des fois la
mode peut-être il pourrait changer
peut-être faire un choc avec g et 6 kg 8
machin il va refaire sa petite muraille
il va attendre le khalife 5e manger le
truc et puis avec ettore faut ni offert
4 et moi j'aimerais bien faire qui lui
cette f5 faut qu'un autre truc mais je
pense que je suis là j'arrive en premier
nom du clos des multiples non en fait
déjà son pseudo j'ai senti qu'il était
dans le ton tu as nuisibles mais jovial
et jovial avec toi j'ai senti qu'en fait
c'est un mec cool quoi mais après on
aime bien faire des envolées comme ça
fasse un peu nombreuses ça défoule
non mon avenir le faire moi je m'en
prends tout le temps à tout le monde ce
sont eux déjà là avant le stream dont
supris à tout le monde
jean-guy la terre entière parce qu'ils
savent pas calculer gérard turquie et
d'anne decis touchait même pas aussi ce
que tu t'exposes à des cas qui va t'en
ferme et on fout enfin donc il mérite et
non mais le seul truc c'est que tu fais
pression sur b2 donc tu peux pas finir
développement qui ont envie et que les
blancs parce que tu as dans rien faire
faut trois tours avait fait un truc
comme ça et c'est ce qui manque
parce que si fils développement ça va
être très chiant points mais au fait
l'enjeu et freewest a tué le jeu femme
vous je dois finir mon développement
jouer trop grands ou qu'il se fut le jeu
je te propose une peut-être h5 profiter
de la dame sait pas et aux trois noms un
peu on peut faire du jeu peut sortir le
football club arts -4 à papa m sur dame
c'est ça qui va faire [ __ ] hu a pour
nom les amendes et 8b 7 à 20 chevaux 3
quand même bon j'ai pas
c'est trop bien phu projet car je
comprends ils te prends tout flambé de
la fin c'est pas un truc qui va pas dans
des vallées sacrifie un truc quand il
est parti pour ça j'ai quand même
l'impression que sa veine c'est mon
style quand j'étais gamin à son
paroxysme quoi c'est très très bien ce
qu'il fait ou quoi mais je pense qu'il a
obtenu le maximum de ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire c'est trop comme dirait besoins de
base trop infantile pas assez profond
non mais c'est pas dans vos ambitions
non mais même si on a envie tu sais
quand même caractéristique les amants
avec ce style tu seras jamais 27,5 en
bas mais je crois pas qui mais il a calé
l'enfer à 26,63 là ne me plaît pas il
peut de 27 du cosynap tirosh way
nombreux peut peut-être que si l'avant
si plus propre pour quoi elle aurait pu
faire plus parce qu'il est quand même
doué qua non ça c'est sûr creed mais il
ya beaucoup de joueurs comme ça
les arméniens les joueurs georges d'ex
yougoslavie sont d'excellents blitzer et
les genres très pratique et qui aime
bien de ce côté là un peu arnaque mais
il promet moins de plaisir à jouer
différemment
non mais je ne sais pas en fait j'avais
toujours s'en remettre mais nous on est
pas foutu à christian couet créatif qui
joue que les ouvertures des petites
lignes des petites idées et tu te dis
oui mais si je les grandes lignes
peut-être très beau coup du sort mais a
fait peut-être pas du tout peut-être
c'est juste ça qui fait son niveau quand
il me serait peut-être pas 2007 s'il se
mettait à jouer des grandes lignes ou
peut-être qu'il le serait mais ce
traitement fait vraiment honneur je suis
pas d'accord avec toi mais peut-être la
raison
il a gagné énormément de partie en fait
justement parce que
mais tes adversaires un peu au ps et que
c'est souligné en ajoutant pesos
compliqué s'il fait bien et qui gagne
comme ça
un choix pratique c'est plus pratique il
n'ya pas cavaler h5 et damages 4 la
cavale et h5 damage 2 d'un match 4
[ __ ] la merde web et vous fera pas
pour notre tour et 8 évidemment voir les
adjugé 3 30 sg 3 bien d'accord avec toi
mais je me battrai pour que tu puisse se
dire non mais je me posais la question à
tour trois peut-être la tour 3 pas mal
de mesure du dom match 2-2 mais on
n'arrive pas à mater pas tout de suite
fait déjà tu es content tu préfères je
crains que tours 8 saïd kahla y en a je
suis tout un g8 ou je ne sais où aller
surtout prend ses cinq torah fou aux 5 c
aux normales avec les blondes 1 mais je
sais pas mais vlad c'est justin a
expliqué un truc fin mon plus gros
défaut il m'a dit que j'étais trop
créatif en fait mais il ya en fait quand
tu penses à des trucs comme ça tu
parasites ton talent fait ce fait tu
penses d'un côté que tu es créatif et où
es tu te vendre des trucs que tu gagnes
mais tu te rends pas compte tout ce que
tu perds en fait c'est ce qui m'a
toujours dit mais yo ka et tu peux
commencer à être créatif quand au moins
là tu peux te permettre à bon ce nom
mais il te dit calme en fait tu ne sais
juste pas joué aux échecs
non seulement parce que ça va passer une
autre caste de joueurs voulaient pas un
band qui te dis oui on pourrait 2600 il
aurait besoin de faire de nous parler
mais je pense que pour lui il a besoin
de faire vraiment c'est juste trop
facile pour les ajuste rotin et qu'après
doit bosser pour faire plus mais néc et
pour la plupart des gens je m'inclus
dedans pas 2006 faut bosser mais du coup
dans ce sens là je pense que c'est bien
d'avoir un style très classique
apprendre à faire du très classique
avant de se mettre à faire autre chose
en fait
mais souvent en fait ces maisons privées
de reina oui j'aime être des cuisiniers
tu apprendras des trucs un débile
d'antrim basique quoi mais à bien tout
faire et après
tu as commencé à mettre des liens
blizzard a tenté de salé sucré le truc
et charest truc hyper bon comme quand
elle est chaud parce que des fois il y
aurait là bas c'est à savoir faire une
omelette bien enfin ce que tu veux dire
bien faire une omelette tu arrêtes toi
ça te paraît facile mais faire une robe
une bonne omelette c'est chaud quoi ta
mok et je vois mon père qui est cuistot
aussi quand ils devront se faire genre
ce qui te fait des op la moquée il s'en
fout et du fait des eaux fly en a [ __ ]
mais a été dit ok mais ça c'est pas des
réseaux enfin il ne respecte pas mal
mais lui ce qui fait ils respectent pas
quand tu fais ça à la maison il est vrai
aux plats qui sépare les blanc du jaune
c'est plus les calculs en premier je
pense que c'est le blanc et le jeune
timothée rey moment ou inversement tout
se passe pas mon métier mais non en fait
ça n'a pas le même temps de cuisson
leblanc que le jaune donc si je fais des
hauts-plateaux mais le blanc et le jaune
en même temps jamais eu personne faire
mais en fait tu fédérer une faute
technique pour m'expliquer non mais
matthias huber s'est déjà battu avant
d'être fusillé 6 et je sais pas faire
quoi qu'on en dise aux places et oui ça
existe vraiment nul non mais peut-être
je sais faire des trucs beaucoup plus
compliqué mais tu restes un sac comme
aux échecs en fait tu vas tu ne voulais
pas pourquoi tu fais bien ouais non mais
tu peux être 2005 mais sans savoir faire
durant la finale deux tours philidor par
exemple possible mais en fait tu as une
herbe incroyable qui manquera soldats
vont peut-être je sais pas en disant je
trouve tellement bien visite entamée à
force de trop qui va finir par perdre le
match pareil toutes les occasions
honnêtement j'ai l'impression que ça a
joué assez mal ce match on n'est pas là
a analysé comme des fous mais si tu
compares mais après on a été gâté 1
jusqu'ici messieurs comparaître les
grilles chat n'est pourrit tout ça mais
en fait c'est juste jour de bios josé
chaque mais que d'habitude la future
voie l'élite mondiale est ok les mecs
c'est incroyable il voit des trucs
vitesse de l'éclair et pme peut faire
des conneries d'ailleurs ça s'empêche
pas mais la pire des temps c'est
fantastique
et là on a vu des eaux des grands
maîtres y performent et plus humain et
qu'en fait un blitz c'est juste de bien
jouer
voilà il est mal al senouar une nouvelle
fois ou f3 ne pas faire c'est simple il
va il va même te faire ces cinq avec le
blanc ouais il tempère me trouve je fais
plein de cours sur des positions comme
ça c'est horrible à jouer mes lordi
pagne pas trop tu fais ces cinq là ok
bien sûr va peut-être pas directeur et
tu peux maintenant quand le temps mais
ouais mais lord il va te donner puis 0,7
puis 0,6 quand même grave et même s'en
foutent recasement je sais fort bien que
l'on sait il pas tant un problème de
l'estrie caisse des cinq noms là j'ai
pas pour toi ce chèque toi tu sais pour
les états en fait le problème des noirs
c'est que talent fou l'esat yema il se
donne beaucoup d'espacé pour aller
passer des tours et attaquer l'on a vu
merci de ne pas le dire pour moi mais tu
vois si je commente avec vlad ça par
exemple j'ai même pas le temps
d'expliquer aux nombreux dire non non
mais toi oui bah oui normalement il faut
dire mais là tu as il va même pas te
laisser expliqué ont battu les
américains qu évident pour lui c'est ça
depuis l'été quoi un effectué sans
fatigue non mes mains mais en fait c'est
pas si simple
il faut que ça tout ça mais c'est vrai
que de faire ces cinq études il oui mais
quand même champion fait bander 4 à 3
des 5 et t'as pas trop envie que diarra
s'est greffée une bonne partie contre jp
l'euro avec exactement ti dfjp qui a
essayé de faire ça et j'avais toi avec
les cavaliers
j'ai fini par payer son pion des 4 après
50 coups de manoeuvre est l'arnaqué dans
le dernier ait été nul j'avais les deux
cavaliers du coup je veux tourner entre
rêves 6,17 machin a eu 7 f 5 matchs pour
avoir la partie était très drôle tu
pourras tu as fait quoi tu tournicoton
mais du coup c'est vrai c'est bien ce
qu'il fait avec les blancs vide et il va
ramer plus verbe et un coiffeur dams et
2004 mais je pense que quelqu'un ici tu
peut claquer un petit damev trois dames
g3 aussi éventuellement ce que dame
froid tu va menacer des cinq voitures
ddamage 3d famille je ferai
voicebox trendchip haut débit de se
fonder nos filiales en assises ou je
sais pas quoi un jour il va faire chaud
et fit pas trop le choix du wild à 7,5
qu'il faut pas oublier les trucs débiles
comme ça je pense offert la mef 3 je
crois au fait n'a pas fait d'un mais
seront premiers personnes mais
franchement s'il ya une personne n'en
est pas un jardin mais toi tu mets la
cc66 foutais à tour devant tu faisais b5
enfin j'veux pas quand ils défendent et
en fait je commence en fait d'un f3
bessin et l'absence à gagner juste en
ligne c'est pas un fable sur une défense
mais non ça tu vas y fais h4 non mais
j'attache 5 et tout mais wade avait
froid il a raté d'un rien rater de la
main froide v5 c'est sûr que ça marchait
non mais tu as raté des trucs comme ça
comme il n'y avait rien à voir ici
non mais évidemment je vais pas dire ça
et maintenant fois à 6 ou dessins qui
est bloqué c'est plus la même femme
qu'elle va faire f 5 qui va tout le fond
des sacs j'en ai joué des milliers des
comme ça
ok la gamme gagné ses six excuses moi je
me suis emballé mais c'est me faire
taper h4 enfin maroc et il est sûrement
toujours mieux mais oui c'était fin
c'est mieux de ne pas voir plus en plus
mondialisé même pas me la met alors le
fond ferment b 17 et un truc si simple à
jouer que ça tu rajoutes de
l'incertitude dans la passion tu as
quand même gagnants non bien sûr
sur ces 7 m ouais mais bon peut-être de
tuer pour avancer cette ouais mais doit
faire mieux maintenant un état le
monstre des cinq mortiers des changes
mais c est un truc un peu fou mais trois
non armés ok mais tu laisses matière à
de fer magouilles et 2 1 parce que le
fait - m6 il sera pas mal placé il va
taper sur des quatre la tourelle va
venir en c2 ten dam provoqué dame prend
à grands pas possible à tuffé tour 2 pts
est il vat encaissé à trois il ya déjà
deux pions van tu vas récupérer
je pense que vaille est celle là enfin
il est tellement grand âge mais il n'a
pas gagné de manière de plus pragmatique
possible le plus méthodiquement ses
étranges 1 quand même j'ai un truc il
est trop facile en fait visiter quoi
même sweat nom ou un an eric fehr pour
ces deux jours dans la tourbe et sa
trompette
je pensais très très bien votre but est
bien aujourd'hui
le truc c'est que c'est un peu comme
dans toutes les parties qu'on voit qu a
dit non mais tête ils vont pas le truc
qu'il trouve sérieux qui est moins
concentré quand réel je suis dit que moi
je sentais pas bien mais peut-être que
lui la scène syndrome tour saint jacques
aux de la 2 way et puis au site et par
l'ambiance tournoi ce n'était pas pas tu
peux te battre tu as tout seul c'est
paco est dans la salle et machins et
dans le truc quoi ta inconsciemment la
trilogie chez toi et se change pas de
tâches en vacances alors où en tout cas
il est tout sourire
mais voilà quoi je sais pas s'il sourit
yves 128 jours avant donc je me souviens
pas mais vous être que c'est mieux vous
à l'heure qu'il est heureux de jouer
peut-être que ça le fait chier en fait
et tu peux pas faire le cas je vais
faire re cadet ed 3 mhnm d'ailleurs du
cac alors il à l'écart a même
intéressant en deux heures il a changé
totalement la de répertoire il a arrêté
les italiennes l'aï fait c'est trop
dominant david aja mêmes chances de gain
et ils souffrent et clément c'est chiant
d'ailleurs visite a pris le leader l'as
du match la première fois il est quand
même tout en contrôlant fab
il est quand même tout en contrôle parce
qu'il était mené 2 0 en début de match
il a assez mal joué je trouve par
rapport à son niveau intrinsèque et
finalement il se retrouve quand même à
plus de
de plus en plus un vrai pardon mais en
ayant l'impression que s'il y avait plus
3 parce que il ya une partie qui l'a
perdue qui devait gagner là quand il
s'est fait arnaquer la dame ou en tweed
ou au moins faire nul dans le gers est
plutôt lui qui se fait mal mais ça sent
le vélo ça parle
il appuie village à 27 22 30
et à ce niveau là 60 70 points c'est
beaucoup c'est plus que entre 1900 et
2000 par exemple mes meilleurs joueurs
ont beau 10 ans et qui est capable d ok
c'est juste on sait pas on verra après a
le bullet toi forezien je sais que c'est
un des meilleurs buteurs du site corps
généralement wade est pas mal mais tu
vois pas remplie est moins fort qu'un
art aux dix kits pour te prendre un
exemple la russie est plus fort mais ne
risquent-ils et 29,50 il a 50 points de
laurent blanc aussi parce que pour le
coup je regardais la finale avec toi
peut-être souvent en comptant son d'airs
donc ils étaient en action il est très
très vite je trouve qu'il joue bien et
il n'a pas laissé de chance à un make
you can skip wifi abattu avant quand il
était dans le bus let it abattu six
rounds en bullet qui est fabriqué le mec
est quand même 3000 en bullet ça va il a
éliminé par goût ambühl est malgré tout
ce qu'on dit pas un grand match un
cafard faut quand même aller le battre
on vu la main mais pas les choses non
mais gère ça reste maintenant sommes
très bons joueurs de belote
richard lui mais kaka mais limitent
théoriquement cheyrou déjà en bullet de
manière assez convaincante et après il a
défoncé kamski fin l'essai de sa tombe
veut faire un truc de tourtour but c'est
une bonne question mais peut-être fait
émis 3 je donne l'impression d'être sur
un problème de la tours et détours
litres mais tu peux tu peux non désolé
juste coupé
mais fou c'est cette québécoise prend
des mythes qui est prendre les deux
tours et les chèques signés prend des
yachts à dessein qui sautent remettant
un ton plus question mon bien aussi
faussé cette date même mieux à faire ce
qui fait que jusqu'à 7 et guident nos
clés la côte revenir alors il se passe
quoi demande martine s'ils sont ex-aequo
après les bulles à tort il rejoue trois
parties une enceinte plus s'inclinant 3
+ 1 et une en un plus un mais six ans un
record à l'égalité je crois que c'est un
bullet armageddon eu quand même c'est
pas mal iago moyens règlement kouassi
jour 72 cup après les deux se qualifient
on sait plus je m'en remets pas que ce
truc là non plus ce n'est pas la
première fois
ce qu'est la vie sinon la jeune
génération
gérard dine r non mais je n'avais pas vu
en direct moi je ce lendemain matin
quand je vois les comptes rendus
j'hallucine totalement ouais c'était
beau moi j'étais assez heureux en fait
ne méritent ils ont expliqué pourquoi
voulais pas faire un mini tournoi trois
joueurs il faut s covent garden 1 mais
en fait ce que caronna s'était déjà
barré mario on était parti de la salle
de jeux donc du coup ben tu l'appelles
ou mais par contre deux langues alors
ils ont appelé mais en fait il voulait
pas parce qu'en fait je prenne c'est
qu'il y avait un autre des partages a
joué contre sow pour le grande chasse
tour et ça le faisait chier de jouer de
départage d'affilée il fait pas la pluie
le beau temps
mais
au pire le dire il est forfait et hyper
quoi ils y ont passé plus importante
degré truc
discutez vous donner la victoire finale
je fais troisième enfin est en fait j'ai
pas compris pourquoi c'est les joueurs
qui ont décidé de jouer enfin sur la
partie évidemment je me rends compte de
la pagaille et matériels pour l'instant
mais le cavalier b3 et très triste et
appuie en d4 en l'air et il y avait là
je dois te plaît de faire du fourrage
trois prises qui est de 5 pour chaque
chose comme cela mais bien étonnant qui
est pas guillemette à la pompe tonne
hockeyville c5 un destin mais chez ba
voila encore toi c'est plus c'est
toujours mieux mais si ça devait
peut-être juste gagner ce match et
pourrait bien comme dit renault après le
machin le pôle e le règlement était mal
fait donc en fait le règlement prévoyait
à skis un tirage au sort parce qu'ils
n'ont pas mis assez de deux facteurs
mais non mais ça arrive c'est déjà
arrivé maman coupe du monde de foot de
papier noble et sam scalia l'on pensé
mais bon j'ai un serbe a tous battus
durant sa mégère tu sais ce qu'est ce
que j'allais dire c'est que tu as signé
un contrat tu dois tirer au sort tu tire
au sort fait à dire qu'est ce que c'est
que ce à quoi non finalement ne veut pas
dire aussi en vain tu dis c'est très mal
fait n'importe quoi vraiment pas l'an
prochain
quand tu le dis ce que tu veux mais non
mais pour moi c'est une honte que les
joueurs puissent faire les règlements
comme sa fin ils sont déjà hyper
grassement payés par rapport au nombre
de gens qui regardent c'est enfin c'est
le sport le mieux payé du monde
j'ai déjà parlé mais en si vous comparez
des audiences que ça fait l'argent
qu'ils gagnent c'est vraiment les
sportifs les mieux payés du monde devant
absolument tous les sports et
et en plus ils peuvent décider les
règles aient refusé de jouer à des
partages quoi mais géré c'est bien pour
le public y aurait beaucoup de gens qui
aura gardé et en plus en fait le fait
car en la toute façon ne vais pas le
jouer bref il est ok dans ces cas là tu
préfères ça nous arrange plus quand ça
nous arrange suis dégagé tirage au sort
thiérache ne t'intéresse pas et tu
laisses faire la finale
thomson a rendu fier le sénat revient
pas c'est pas moi ça m'a paru vraiment
de délirant mais l'uci aurait été dans
la merde s'il avait été trois qualifiés
pour le grand duché ce tour taquet
france 5 est le tenant
mary kay france un caillou de
l'harmattan merad quand même des trucs
fage et kaki et français 1 qui comprend
qu avait lieu deux femmes
franchement ça c'est court mais disons
que dans le lait petit exercice comme le
bluff ou quoi non mais ok femme est en
fait mais moi si je rate ça avec leurs
plats avec leur canon suis déçu d'avoir
raté pas je vois tout de suite après
honnêtement ça joue mal je sais pas
quelle est la raison parce que c'est des
joueurs qui sont le répète un mille fois
plus fort que nous il ya aucun souci là
dessus mais ce soir les deux jouent
quand même très mal après il ya la
fatigue à machin mais on n'a pas été
habitué à ça dans les dents les autres
matches un fab
l'aïe a quand même un nombre de gav qui
est assez est ce que c'est la rose et du
printemps de l'été
je sais pas la fin de l'été ce que mais
bon là c'était quand même assez évident
qu'ils n'ont pas vu les deux c'est le
mec avec l'élan a perdu mais cas est
énorme en plus et je crois en ses
pelures avec les noirs que les blancs
que tu y joues visite soit tu fais un et
on tenait cette occasion tu dois faire
tempo est encore rendu la vie dure à
joues blêmes et queen secondes
donc non la voix repas sont à ce jour
nul pas même les bourses un peu je peux
être sûr de rigueur mais tu crois dessin
peut-être votre épée les 9 et 5 passes
et de gagner pêcha qui dit les footeux
sont mieux payés
je pense pas parce qu'il coupe de monde
de football ça intéresse en gros deux
milliards de personnes et l'asim que
phil cup ça intéresse deux cent mille
personnes à tout casser et entre 200000
et 2 milliards
t'as quoi ta coeff 1000 et auquel et
loire de foot fin à la karl scène ils
gagnent dans les dents les deux millions
d'euros par an et peut-être même plus
c'est ok ronaldo vous croyez quand même
pas 2 milliards d'euros par an hab ce
soir santé pour les chroniques riche
agent à logan 2 milliards par an sur une
période de dix ans il sera à 20
milliards d'euros je pense pas qu'ils
passent d'un milliard d'euros le mec pas
ok ils étaient tous bonne sort ce machin
a passé à côté d'un mais c'est pas 2
milliards
de toute façon même façon je pense pas
mais enfin mais non mais le sportif qui
a gagné le plus c'était tiger woods ya
quelques années quand il est arrivé à un
milliard et là on serait sûr de deux
milliards par an sera une carrière de 15
ans ça lui ferait même s'il est pas au
top tout le temps ça lui ferait une
minimum 20 milliards d'euros mais c'est
ok tu deviens quasiment bill gates
mais comme dit à asperger le problème
c'est par les joueurs tu vas changer le
règlement c'est les organisateurs qui
acceptent tu dois jamais accepté un truc
pareil tu dois juste les envoyer chier
en fait normalement mais pour ça te fera
jamais un gros truc où ceux-ci du film
ne sera pas l'équivalent d'un tournoi
avec une vraie tradition vraie nouvelle
histoire une institution car si c'est un
truc c'est juste les joueurs font ce
qu'ils veulent ce qui compte c'est faire
le jeu le 2 kong 2 à la fin les machins
qui sont là pour rigoler pour l'argent
oui c'est ça en fait mais d'heure ils se
marient 1 quand ils refaisaient le
règlement ça j'étais mort de rire en
fait quand tu vois la vidéo il rigole
quoi ils discutent du joueur on fait ça
on fait ça c'est honteux c'est vraiment
pendant 2 ou non mais pas de la part des
joueurs de la part des organisateurs
normalement tu dois les recadrer les
remettre à leur place et leur dire vous
jouer c'est pas la fête
enfin vous êtes payés wimbledon s'est
affaibli en rouge igoogle et l'allemande
et où il refait et refaire le même match
perdu à force on t'a votre federer
toujours en blanc quatuor intérêts peut
poser qu'il ya aussi les frais d'hôtel
et les transports non non c'est frais
d'hôtel payée pour eux pour les seconds
en la bouffe des fois tu as des starting
filles qui sont pas écrits non plus
taïz un des mécènes souvent qui paye les
seconds en enfin en fait ils ont
beaucoup de davantage en plus dont on
parle pas là dedans et là par exemple
pour la grande finale à londres déjà le
dernier je crois qu'il ya déjà trente
mille minimum je crois que celui qui est
le vainqueur c'est 120 milles donc
rien que sur une saison de grande chaise
sortu peut déjà faire 200 mille dollars
en ayant joué quatre tournois face est
énorme et ça rapporte jamais rien aux
organisateurs enfin
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici on veut 5 non
mais tu as skinny pascal oci meilleurs
sportifs sur le niveau son pays sans les
plus forts sont plus une centaine de
millions
donc si tu pas vraiment fait un stuc on
part en terme d'intérêt de machin de vue
les échecs c'est mieux payés que le foot
que le tennis faut le savoir mais pas
juste pour dire quand tu joues le
rassure toi tu fais le rassure mais
juste pour venir y ait une pour jour un
truc comme la prod chez sling sur une
soirée une compétition amicale à moins
de 500 dollars
le match n'a aucun joueur du top 100
mondial genre aucun mais ok c'est une
compétition amicale sur internet rien en
jeu et déjà la 500 la soirée c'est pas
assez
paris tu as ça veut dire beaucoup quand
même et les cashprizes bas ils sont
payés par du mécénat ou de l'argent
public ça dépend mais mes parents que la
le speech est ce qui est financé par de
l'argent privé ya beaucoup moins
d'argent en fait par exemple la halle
dans ce match je crois qu'il ya sur
toute la saison de speechless et d'avoir
cinquante mille dollars en jeu ou
quelque chose comme ça pour les joueurs
et si tu perds pas le terme de match et
machin ses vrais parents
laurent vous compte des points qu'ils
font dans le match ouais farhat à 1000
dollars qui va au vainqueur et après les
les autres mille îles sont partagés
entre les joueurs au prorata morvan mais
si tu compares par rapport au tour de
haut niveau c'est beaucoup moins bien
payés en fait dès que tu as de l'argent
privé c'est ta des trucs réaliste et
c'est beaucoup plus suivie que la sinne
que le fils cup c'est plus suivis le
speech est ce que la think you feel cap
c'est important de le savoir faire
vas-y beauty en france la plus la moitié
des joueurs vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté mais pas des noms mais
huawei des pronostics je regarde un
chèque c'est que t'as plein de joueurs
d'échecs qui sont pas dans ce top 100
mondial ou même top 200 ils vont te dire
ok je suis joueur d'échecs mais dans
tous les sports c'est comme ça je
rappelle à 0,7 ou quoi mais aussi gars
comme chou franchement tu peux faire
cavalier f5 oui je prends comprendre et
à d'autres besoins et tué des cloisons
six mois tu peux aussi faire dame g7 et
f4 mais à tour jésuite qui va être chaud
et parfois de ses cinq jeux qui défend
mcqueen n'est ce pas madrid commence par
cavani f5 dans le figaro qui met est
évident et ça toi qu'est le jeu
bon je crois que c'est une pièce dans le
désert et en faire un petit rap ou plus
au prochain match et risque fédérale 1
dernier l'a gagné 77 millions de dollars
en 2017
mais tu vois par rapport à un magnus qui
va et qui va prendre en dollars
peut-être dans les deux mignons fin tu
as ça me paraît beaucoup par rapport aux
77,2 federer femmes perso parce que
rogers quand même c'est assez
impressionnant fait lui plaisait pas
marrant la rue il vrai que pas marcher
dans la rue tranquille c'est impossible
et puis c'est une légende je sais pas
non mais enfin je vous sais bien que tu
utilises ton sport et tout ça au sol par
l'arrêt a été déjà dit mon point de vue
moi je trouve que c'est bien que les
joueurs gagnent beaucoup et je suis
plutôt pour mais le problème c'est que
c'est bien s'ils gagnent autant enfin tu
vois si tu me dis les joueurs ils ont 2
millions d'euros il ya 20 millions
d'euros pour l'organisation des tournois
là je suis très content mais quand le
plus gros de ce qui est payé ça va aux
joueurs
en fait tu va à l'encontre de quasiment
tous les sports en fait et de tout ce
qui peut marcher mais comme marketing
book
non en fait ça à l'envers en fait tu ne
fais absolument rien pour le produit et
eu en fait on va vraiment ce que tu veux
avec ton argent s'est pas tu assez
bizarre en fait ce que deux bases en
fait tu marches comme une entreprise
fait un tout marche comme ça tu veux que
les gens regardent ton sport et machin
c'est pas juste une distribution
d'argent à des mecs pas tu as ça
n'existe pas en fait placé de l'argent
gratuit on sait même pas pourquoi en
fait pas assez juste un peu bizarre
comme manière de fonctionner mais bon
j'en ai déjà souvent parlé mais bon t'as
personnes qui en parle aussi
on y par contre après le top 10 a pas
beaucoup d'argent mais enfin je pense
que tous les joueurs du top 50 mondial
j'oubliais ville va assez bien faible en
oisans mesure ça descend vite ensuite
là bas il cavaliere la femme de 25 ans
c'est fini à yaoundé iv mais non mais
jaro tennis il ya beaucoup d'argent
enfin il ya de l'argent pour les 50
premiers angot qui vraiment bien aux
échecs peut-être pour les grandes
familles non je ne sais pas exactement
mais bon après on s'en sort et puyoô
d'échec il n'ya pas le gens ne font pas
que jouer et qui donne des cours on sait
que modélisme des mecs font preuve dans
les clubs
non mais je vois là rien que pour le
showdown de la sinne que phil cap qui va
se jouer
premier enfant mais ok ça va se jouer là
du 11 au 14 septembre
un mec comme l'anglais un mec comme
chancelante qui est genre 35e mondial il
va prendre cinquante mille dollars pour
jouer quatre jours enfin en gros c'est
agir c'est du niveau de paille les 30e
mondial il va prendre 50 milles en 3
jours et topalov bon ok il a été bien
mais il est loin maintenant et ils vont
tous prendre autant en fait mais c'est
beaucoup d'argent
et en plus ça c'est vraiment un truc
amical et c'est un manque d'ambition cme
ces exhibitions tu francs cinquante
mille par jour à main et tu vas avoir
peut-être 4000 spectateurs sur internet
gratuit ce côté nice en plus il ya plus
de spectateurs mais les gens payent pour
le voir vas y prennent des abonnements
been sport ils payent des places depuis
le stop est content de rejouer c'est
cher car on en parlait juste avant avec
nos abonnements canal + par ailleurs tt
était prêt à payer presque 400 par an
pour le voir jouer mais hélas aux échecs
tu as beaucoup moins de gens qui
regardent sans fondement une personne
qui regarde et en plus c'est des gens
qui regardent gratuitement parce qu'il
payerait pas pour voir donc
non mais ça qu'on parle de ça au final
c'est pour faire un peu de pédagogie
peut-être l'organisation du coup on en
est où la liasse même temps dans ce soit
bien ça vraiment serré jusqu'au bout
alejo feu quatre écoutes il reste plus
que 11 minutes
il reste 15 minutes
au niveau 7 kg 6 pi et f4 de nouveaux
qui arrivent et non non il refait cette
vanne ans il refait cette variante
il insiste à fond mais souffrent je
trouve n'arrive d'avancé talent n en
était rien faire son tour f 1.4 d'un an
je suis à soupçonnant qu'on me dira de
d'ouverture ce truc là
l'arrêté qu'il allait jouer ce n'était
pas trop mal passé comme alors le risque
il met l'art de maîtriser sa grison qui
auraient pu faire cette visite à kiev
là je sais mais bon il a aimé ce qu'eric
et noir cette symétrie avec le groupe le
contre gries des 4es du coup c'est une
autre avantage de deux buts la tuque ya
tout eu faire des tours des huit tours
nuitées ça s'échange le 5 août était
bien moins marrer quand il joue pas mal
j'ai dit mais bon je pense qu'on peut
être d'accord sur le fait que visite il
est surtout très bon en stratégie
placement de pièces et tout ça est
mauvais donc au niveau tactique
en tout cas ce soir ce soir et
[Musique]
et adrian linverse les bizarres se sont
en tout comme les arméniens une
stratégie ils sont ils sont là quand ils
ont une bonne école ouais mais je crois
qu'ils aiment bien faire les petits jeux
de magouilles oui on savait ce que tu
sais c'est qu'ils aiment bien en fait
sur le problème c'est pas le sait pas
qui savent pas faire c'est juste ça les
amuse pas ça va d'accueil les mecs très
sage en arménie en vidéo rognon gens
parlent pas mais el jamri même si je
pense à la musique juste il peut pas
faire s'ils jouent trop d'effort joie
mais mes sargis y en mai le coup niant
mais comme ça c'est quand même très très
rigoureux mes parents mon obsession
c'est déjà autre chose
il adore jouer des trucs un peu vide
assez brillant comme c'est surtout leur
show mais il est bien les arméniens là
je parle des whalers genre d'équipés
nationales en la qualifiant akopian
c'est assez rigoureux comme aussi chose
on va tomber les vieux arménien et le
coup d envoi gagnant
charles aznavourian passe me voir et
m'ont mais en fait c'est son rêve
d'ailleurs certaines blagues s'appelle
vraiment aznavourian gens l'appellent
aznavour mais à saint-vaury meilleur
plus tôt anne nazarian petrosyan tu vois
à vientiane / à savoir du coup il a pris
un monde sanac aznavour c'est juste les
gens qui ont pris un diminutif qu'il se
rester non je crois qu'en fait quand il
a pris son quand il a obtenu la
nationalité française il a juste entendu
avoir enlevé le jan je crois mais j'ai
pas sûr à vérifier mais je n'étais pas
au courant
à vérifier non mais c'est peut-être une
connerie inquiète faut vérifier mais
juste en russe en russie en fait foi les
arméniens quand tu quand tu es français
à moscou et que tu rencontres un
arménien souvent et beaucoup d'argent et
que son taxi ils disent sous jules
charles naouri yann quand ils sont très
contents
non non pas que j'étais assez
choqué c'est que copa en fait des
copains chef ce qui m'est jamais entendu
va durer 2 quand il est mort après
j'aurai vu des trucs mais c'est comme si
moi en fait tous appelés libye libye
libye libye et que c'était juste europe
1 c'était écrit comme ça dans tous les
magazines dans tous les livres dans les
compos les parties d'échecs
tu dois sortir assouvie ok après
maintenant 50 ans tout rond pense que
oui kate c'était juste pour moi mais mes
copains j'étais vraiment pas au courant
je pense que c'est son nom raymond kopa
non je n'avais pas en fait un tueur
copeaux chomsky ouais mais tu peux
changer ton en fait je peux francisé ton
nom quand je dis aux français
tu as le droit en fait si tu veux je te
franciser les malades en fait il voulait
faire un truc fantastique fait quand je
suis devenu français
il vous les appelez vlad blitz en fait
je crois qu'ils n'ont pas voulu mais je
veux compte facebook s'est passé
vraiment demander finalement aussi un
coquet fallait qu'ils obtiennent le
passeport et qu'il arrête avec ses
demandes bizarre parce que hockey de
catch est fade quatre shows par exemple
je sais pas s'il va si tu conserves
c'est plus français d'enlever le jan les
deux ça peut-être ils le font mais je
vais en studio et je vais peut être
quatre chefs vous êtes blitz français
mais ses pronostics mais il est immature
les corps étaient très heureux de
s'appeler black beach kg vous du coup
kevin bitstream comme si tu changes de
pays ouais je peux le dire mais voilà
pour la petite anecdote
voilà cette partie le petit visite le
petit jeu la tige de gens en valais on
se sera pas un enthousiasme à fond pour
ce match fab home se fera qu on parle
beaucoup on n'en a pas mais après tout
il n'ya pas de grandes envolées donc je
instants après peut-être ambulatoire
doute on a parlé de ça est là on en peut
rigoler mais monde est nerveux vent mais
c'est vrai que c'est mais aussi salué le
fait que je sais pas je suis fatiguée
parce que en fait j'ai cogité à riga ne
jamais aborder des jeunes et on est la
beta 3 années du match j'ai pris l'avion
une correspondance machin je pense par
marceau et qui était je suis pas au
taquet pour réaliser des variantes non
mais après le truc c'est que ça pas
[Musique]
quand on a dit qu'on allait les qualités
des partis est quand même un peu je sais
pas c'est pas un match qui est inspirant
je dirais non non c'est un peu pour ça
disent quoi redire c'est parti à ces
noms qui sont pas très propre il suffit
souvent de manière un peu rocambolesques
c'est peut-être le mambo match qu'on
voit d'ailleurs je pense mais dans le
côté ça est intéressant le bullet bas à
environ moins le côté on ne sait pas qui
va gagner c'est à dire 7,7 david souvent
les machos assez vite plié acheté un
bébé de en fait fin je comprends genre
même c'est quoi devez tout content
qu'ils jouaient nadeau 3-1 peut-être
tour à tour un tut tut ap la tour après
tu faire allez peut-être en échec à la
barre est non mitoyenne qu'un jeu c'est
bien ce qu'il fait il serait difficile
avant de partir en vrille
et domine bien domine bien il a 14
secondes a pas mal bougé quatre récits
et je conçois peut-être qu'ils dominent
gaz d'ailleurs vous êtes tentés juste
rennes a fait un clip only way est
accueilli sur fion 3 kg 400 fr damas de
forêts ou d'amd de à laisser taper des
cinq étoiles à ses ventes et un prénom à
sauver d'autres personnes
jean maillet tournant et de manger
quatre étrangers car ils auraient fait
seulement du cliff kim aux commentaires
je fais pareil ouais mais regarde il se
fait même du cas d'échec est juste
surréagi vite
non mais je sais pas c'est tellement
bizarre voilà ça m'a d'autres ya plus de
menaces via les 11
donc si peur pas celle-là je veux
propulser mesdames f1 hockey marc mais
heureusement qu'il a perdu à 80 quoi il
veut le faire tomber
mais peut-être perpète en plus d'âme ses
huit échecs et s'était pas fait en fait
les deux il est tombé mais damas m dames
cité et cavaliers hafid un profit 3,7 à
m'y intéresser des farc le yen vers 7
minutes du drame et dames this way mais
roy fuite et tu te ramène ta tour que le
colisée mais on regrettera juste c'était
pas mal joué en fait non mais tu assez
étonnant ce que de passes tu as quand
même pièce de plus pion à deux fins
enfin ça doit juste gagner tout seul ça
non c'est étonnant fable comme match bah
ça je peux y parvient on va essayer de
voir retomber suspense et une partie
père décisif dans le money-time voit là
dessus ça me fait peur par rapport à moi
ce que ce que ça doit être quand je
peins
ça va tellement est une pure nous quoi
non mais quand tu vois un truc comme ça
sérieux ça te démoralisant fait ce que
tu vois des mecs comme ça sur 10 10 10
parties si je perds 8,2 je suis super
heureux en gros je pense que j'ai fait
enfin je sois mais parce que là il ya
une pression s'y ajoute ça devant
tellement de public
enfin je sais pas au rythme passer pour
un con dans tout le monde c'est un truc
l'autre in red shirt s ils sont pas
habitués à jouer avec autant de public
et donc que ça peut peut-être c'est un
peu inhibés ok c'était aussi des sommes
choqués yam il ya mille ans je la
qualifie après tu en plus un match qui
peut être encore gagnable si tu as vu ce
qu'ont demi a peut-être au final 3 à
4000 euros qu'on va apprendre s'il gagne
deux matches plaident ça désinhibe un
peu apprécié par je pense 4000 euros
pour un joueur comme vie dit c'est pas
énorme
un joueur comme vidic doit quand même
tourné dans les cinquante soixante mille
euros par an de soutien va je sais pas
mais ce que je sais pas tu me suis là je
sais qu'il aille chercher un club de
toulouse par le vous donc non mais pas
même sa vie je sais pas trop
d'enseignements jeu
j'ai tout connu et de chez plein mais
potentiellement signer un club en
allemagne et tout ça est déjà il gagne
déjà pas mal ok les tournois les machins
les olympiades tu as et je me fais pas
de souci pour lui quoi enfin dire que
trois à quatre mille euros c'est pas ça
c'est pas une somme qui doit le tua qui
doit l'inhiber mais peut-être le public
après un public sait quelque chose
pamela une nouvelle fois en fait après
vingt coups j'ai l'impression qu'il a
débité la théorie que les positions
justes c'est écrasant pas fatwire les
scénarios parti c'est souvent comme ça
quand même hein c'est ok mais là tu vas
pas réussir à ok espace écrasant que ça
j'ai peut-être un peu déconné fab en mai
de base cela nous permet enfin à vue
d'oeil telle est l'impression que ça
devait être quasi fini par sur tourbe et
ça tu as he ok je pense
in time has come b3 d'enfermer ouais
c'est bien joué et sur calais prend
hiver du tour b1 est fou c'est un je
vais montrer qu'à et prend tourbe et un
soin qui est à katia tour b4 et surtour
des mythes ya flou ses amis et et 3,17
surtout ces aides a bâclé à tour et tu
te des clous je sais pas à quel point ça
marche bien tu peux faire
tu peux faire [ __ ] ans et six femmes
et b3 ou pas autant qu'elles coûtent
juin foot un f6 et b3 bonne ok jurés
peuvent penser forcément c'est sûr ça
marche je perdais d'éroder celle des
trucs intermédiaire wyrwa 17 je fais
tour eiffe points à kébé de te cacher
droixhe un cac à mais je vais te taper f
6 à 6 ou f6 en tout cas non mais ok
c'était intéressant un candidat
franchement je fais labs et l'enferment
tenue n'est peut-être pas tomber quatre
tombes et vita vous vous tournez un
certain faire brasser sets et va s'en
sortir mon truc c'était pas mal un fou
prend b3 le feu seulement corps j'essaie
de faire vous savez ça marche mais ça
doit d'être créatif d'être un thème
rarement vu et peut-être salle injuste
ou plus après ça peut-être que ça marche
aussi un mais montait tour ces huit là
plutôt tu laisses les pions g7 et toutes
actives à fond tout racheté 8 têtes qui
est on rangeait ses trois réussissent
voilà souvent l'activité sacs les plus
importants après et même temps je ne
sais pas s'il ya un gros problème allait
arriver
je vais passer comme ça j'irais plutôt
dans quand on y goûte à proposer ou
comme lui fait d'ailleurs très bien sûr
tour f 2 il ya car elle y était un héros
j'ai un pc
non mais c'est exactement ce non pas
quand je pense que cette partie est régi
super bien le match en fait c'est manque
de précision des banques et séduire de
préciser chaque nom mais peut-être
séduire tous les sports de bien jouer ça
ces bateaux ce que je raconte quand on
parle du foot notamment matches de ligue
1 et déjà les mecs on les gagne sont
bons mais qu'en fait il se passe rien
c'est horrible je 00 tu te dire en fait
c'est peut-être super dur de bien jouer
au foot
mais que les échecs comme la même mais
parfois vous caps à nous qu avocat
non mais là ce qui m'étonne c'est qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup d'erreurs
tactiques qu'on a vu en fait s'agir moi
d'habitude je vois juste rien je ne peux
rien
les cinq athlètes tour des deux échecs
ne fait des abruzzes marrant ces trois
des cinq tours à 5.446 roy croit droite
reprend la caisse du cabinet ouais mais
bon peut-être fait juste trois sets a
réussi cette finale auxquels on peut
faire mieux que 5 où on va vers quel
registre des s'être c6 ou pas les
matches ici et maintenant on peut
l'enlever vite on plonge ici si tu peux
mais ça valait au mépris de passe ouais
c'est au tour à 5 3 et 6 ouais non mais
ça n'en mets tour des de la femme moi je
fais tourner et de rêveries d'accord
autour des deux trois ou quatre tours à
4,3 prendre trois tours france et 2
allez petit peu allant f5 après qu'est
ce que c'est souvent comme ça ça encore
mais pas trop non mais c'était bien
content de 2000 pour sauver tous après
je sais pas à quel point ça l'est resté
totalement mais c'est mieux que ça ça
c'est indéniable non mais bombay revient
encore quoi ils s'accrochent et erin
moule à son rocher prend et gt3 ils
avaient bloqué des options de plus non
mais tu vois ce qui m'étonne c'est que
j'ai pas l'impression qu'après on doit
vendre il ya certains trucs qu'on doit
dire de la merde hein clairement mais de
toute façon il ya énormément d'erreurs
tactiques c'est hallucinant on a
beaucoup de pros beaucoup trop c'est
énorme et tactique emblée ce fait
important
non mais j'ai l'impression que ça joue
moins bien que un match tu mais c'est
pas bon d'en reparler de naro 10 qui par
exemple mais je pense eu mes meilleurs
narrow disent qu'ils savent mieux
vraiment après je veux qu'on sorte vite
- rouge alors que les deux mais
peut-être c'est ce soir et qui a une
dynamique de ma situation à partir comme
ça les solex notre étonnant s'étonnant
vecd style qui se dit pas que sont pas
compatibles à tout âge
live parce qu'elle m'a dans tous les cas
révélés normaux
les chercheurs pensent qu'il n'est pas
juste pas vu que caisse est choquant
même temps là il a vu qu'une trois
minutes
non c'est fini en fait trois arrêts 8,8
sa part en ville est bombardée serré
quoi sens pour apple en veut non mais
nombre de gaffes étonnant et c'est le
cas cassez quasiment rassure en quoi ce
que tu as des fois nous aussi on a nos
mauvais jour nouvelle soirée on s'en
veut beaucoup et on se dit oui comment
jeu je joue aussi mal et où enfin
surtout moi le 1er mai
mais là non je pense qu'on peut dire
sans trop prendre de risques si on prend
la qualité du jeu des deux joueurs
ensemble c'est le match de ce pitch est
ce le plus faible de l'histoire ce que
d'habitude quand il ya un massacre il ya
un mec vraiment fort qui défonce là
c'est ces mutuelles quoi oui / non c'est
autant qu'en faveur franchement que ces
deux bons joueurs
non mais ça il faut surtout pas enfin tu
as bien raison de le redire quoi c'est
surtout pas une critique envers leur
niveau et ça veut pas dire que s'il
avait joué un autre jour il aurait joué
à ce niveau là c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui
voilà c'est peut-être les deux sont pas
en france arrive en tête et pas en forme
en même temps et c'est tout un jeu tout
genre mutuellement vers le bob rae et
fille dans l'esprit de faire pire non
mais la partie où il avait une pièce de
plus le machin le truc hallucinant aussi
où il redonne la tour on a en face était
celle là c'était le bon coup
non mais ça arrive enfin j'ai rien à
dire c'est incroyable les bombes huet ça
nous promet des rebondissements
c'est le gange ce match fade c'est le
gange de sucre ouais c'est vrai que
contre eux wesley so bon là c'est facile
si ça joue comme ça c'est faux c'est
même pas la peine
après je pense pas qu'il joue aussi mal
contre sow pas pire temps plus tard
elles seront parfois rude il offre non
mais je pense pas que ça puisse
tard renault existent ils flippent tard
si j'ai raté un coup je me fais défoncer
parquet avait compagne mais en fait
c'est pas évident de jeu des trucs comme
ça en direct sur scène quoi parce que
cette dimension là où tu es pas me dire
je garde quand tu es devant ma tv
publiques aux airs skate
non moi je sais parfois j'avais fait
nationale dont j'étais plus jeune mais
tu vois je suis un peu tétanisé quoi car
j'ai mal joué façon j'étais moins fort
que le pouvoir des joueurs présents mais
mais où est passé en plus à l'époque
c'était sur scène c'était quand même
plus prestigieux pas non mais non pas
comme ça et si une fois il est un
tournant à aix-en-provence des trucs
comme ça avec des cartes final les trucs
avec wade qui se trouve sur scène c'est
autre chose on prend l'habitude de ce
genre de choses on est pas sur scène
mais tu es chez toi ok et peu importe
mais ta boîte à des milliers de gens des
dizaines de milliers de gens qui te
regardent n'était c'était une pression
qui ne t'a pas élu d'entre eux quand tu
fais ton petit open
même s'il faut pas oublier aussi avant
que ça reprenne excuse moi te couper
mais c'est d'utiliser le hashtag speech
est ce pour vous prendre en photo fait
about me donne quoi parce que on a des
photos photos là gérard quoi j'allais
voir le twitter y at il un vrai choix
des red sox
c'est peut-être l'énergie de artaq quoi
tu te prends du artaq dans la gueule
enfin à séduire coiffant faut quand même
à assumer artaq non à charge pour toi
c'est facile tu es chez toi mais tu as
partage chez toi parce que tu as déjà
joué en présence de l'artac non bas car
tu me compare le national ou 20000
spectateurs qu'est ce que tend à faire
quoi
[Musique]
mais bon c'est la veine qui était mort
de rire aussi donc tête il est enfin je
pense qu'ils savent qu'ils font plein de
gaffer qui joue n'importe comment les
dents mais bon c'est un match ouvert fab
non mais après tout pas se voir parce
que ça c'est la vie en plus d'apparaître
le match pour ça tu encore ta chance
donc ce qui est fait est fait piola faut
savoir rebondir
tel un ballon tel un melon imposable
je sais pas moi j'essaie de trouver des
mères est 8 e mail à chanter me quant à
ray dans le casque quoi et tu te
retrouves quoi on attend ce pitch est ce
que je sais pour ça
j'y passe très bien marché assure cette
chanson-là chanter ni quand a réussit
pas du tout d'ailleurs réservé aux
femmes battues
tu te bats mais je suis là mais je
cherche le hashtag a speech assez je
vois pas de photos le gentil fils qu'est
ce que c'est que ça asie les langues
font ça mais céder american ba n est ce
pas ce qu'ils font nous on n'a pas trop
d'heures abbassi voulait payer
d'abonnement combien ou pour vous
et oubliez pas voulu prendre les photos
avec les brosses à dents attaque que
bono où il n'y a rien à gagner juste
pour le délire quand même acheté à coups
de hache taglit stream tchèque ce que
vous voulez moi j'ai fait bon donc le
ridicule ne tue pas que ça va on peut
faire des bras serait ridicule que c'est
génial au contraire même vous aime bien
mais bon peut-être que vous [ __ ] c'est
ridicule mais que je dis que du pass à
graver au pire c'est une photo sur
internet vous serez dans le brosser les
dents
j'ai même fait pendant la vidéo qualifie
carrément brosser les dents pendant le
truc mais c'était trop fort quoi
prennent trop de mouvements monter dans
la bouche mais j'en pouvais plus en fait
je sais
[Musique]
c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire non mes chansons sont
super pas forme qu enfin c'est ce que je
sais quand je fais des trucs fous non
mais donne mais en fait il a une bonne
tête non son président j'ai vu un gif là
où il fait tour à 8.8 il s'en rend
compte avant et une tête non l'avait
fait avant doigts et repart de l'avant a
disparu route est parti non en fait il
est assez marrant
enfin moi j'aime bien en fait du coup et
les fans mais bon il en sueur non mais
là oui tout ça va me prendre une crise
bien que qui a un rendu dans la
prochaine partie basse est possible en
2000 y croit j'aurais abandonné
j'ai envie de jouer simple le tour a
fuit ce que tu le perds tu tombes sur
quoi je sais pas où je serais trop
dégoûté peu de voir tous étions passés
depuis l'an de gaffes quoi ils
s'accrochent en suisse en qui calcule
des trucs et on la sort edwards et des
trois c'est la plus simple c'est
l'option hyper important de la chaîne de
pions date aurait pas eu 4 à la rigueur
et j'attends un peu de moi mais tu
mettrais le fond j'ai deux tu fais un
truc détroit en fait juste eu tout
collapse dans la position y résiste un
mois il va perdre c'est quand même
incroyable fini de manger quatre sages
indiens
ça le fait marrer 3 2 à 3 ans elle peut
prendre le domaine et ça m'a fait marrer
vie disent qu'il était mort de rire
frappe qui rigole pas grand chose mais
il est marrant il est heureux de tout un
taux bien le crimson
bah ouais c'est cool d'avoir sur la
variante voilà du coup une fois ce truc
s'est passé est extraordinaire
alors des 5 et vite va te cacher quoi
donc et à 5 bis tv sat pdci sait pas ce
qu'il fait part plus tôt sur ce thème il
n'y a pas des beckham déjà d'être pote
peut-être pas encore oui oui ça traduit
aucune velléité saint chaffray bicis
quinze jours en vous mettant dans son
cavalier qui peut se faire attraper ces
quatre peut-être aller à les foules mais
les titulaires
la visite à turin minutes non mais
visiter hockey quoi qu'il en soit il a
quand même dominé tout le match mais
metz devra avoir tiré les tours m faux
procès ok enfin m6 nous bombay il a bien
joué en coupe d'europe
bon je me lève le prouve mais de vous à
moi je me chauffe bon la chambre claque
qu'est ce que c'est que ça détroit a dit
natif il est connecté
je reviens non c'est fou
mais en fait c'est peut-être juste la
différence entre genre de l'élite et les
grands maîtres même fort grand mettre
entre guillemets norbourg est vraiment
grand c'est juste fou qu'en faite par
mme hamouri fans qui comme une bonne
chose un bon joueur de ligue 2 je peux
promettre une fille c'est un des rares
joueurs à 2681 ce qui est beaucoup quoi
est cema s'est fait votre contrat car
c'était assez 28,2 que le match pas où
va tout cet ennemi denis je sais pas
mais c'est à peu près du même niveau que
sebastian après le niveau qu'ils ont eus
et entre les deux relais entre les deux
ce qui est hallucinant
salut c'est juste donc normal qu'on voit
au final juste qu'on a pas l'habitude
mais après les tontons l'habitude de me
voir moi c'est pas je sais qu'il s'agit
d'un match à matt puisque mon sont des
patrouilles de ça ça serre cavalier e 5
le reprendre juste après ce logo c'est
encore le gange passé horrible
[Musique]
j'ai 3 way
bernie tu perds h3 tu perds les cases
blanches étaient au niveau du matériel
quoi faire mais ok il peut être un peu
déçu d'être un plaisir parce que je
crois que il est sa chance aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils n'aiment pas oui
aujourd'hui et ce match mais je sais pas
mais est ce que je veux dire c'est que
vie dit je pense qu'elle a vraiment j'ai
bientôt new c'est sûr et au ps il mec
est vraiment un jour sans c'est ta
chance ou jamais de l'accrocher le truc
non mais je pense que vie dit il peut
pas jouer moins bien
randria science je ne sais pas mais j'ai
dit il à 0 % c'est clair ne peut pas
être moins bien pour moi c'est évident à
la zone 2 minutes donc il a fait une
sorte de trois poisons
or deux coups bizarre de carnival
m'intéresse c'est que t'as pas mickey en
c3 donc sur le 4 août aip appris qu'elle
prend ses trois b prend et c5 et c'est
plutôt une bonne version pour les blancs
il veut des joueurs d'une folle d'avec
les nord vaut mieux éviter ce genre de
choses témoigne un rêve pour un bullet
ou quoi donc ça va pas le déranger
puisque ça mais objectivement faut
éviter plus ce qu'alice réunion c6 que
le bac à 4 4
on sent qu'ils calment un peu dominé
dans le but est plus encore dans last
donc je pensais a été vraiment dominé
tout le match parce que niveau niveau
pendule et ou encore gagné il ya deux
secondes d'avancé et apprendra que trois
bizarre d afrique ok pas une un bon fond
des saints qui il va tenter si ces trucs
ou vendre en jeu c'est vraiment ce qui
va la gagner celle-là c'est ce genre de
parti qui gagne alors comment si votre
ado ce mec
si celle ci frappe non mais ces jeux
sont pas des décompensations fond de
pions d'accord et a pas de compenser non
mais qu'est ce qui les documents anciens
qui prend b2 est ce que tu peux faire
mais tu peux même pas des échecs qui
fauche 6 mai pour un pion sans
l'adoption c'est quand même tout c'est
incroyable
mais quelques secondes avant ce pain il
va la gagner c'est incroyable je pense
je suis sûr prof
moi j qui la gagne grâce à ce très beau
ça relancera match en plus mais pour ça
jancovici et souffrons me trompe pas on
va chercher dit qu'il a gagné et pour
que sept secondes d'avancé ni refait son
retard il bouffe une qualité plus en
plus d'organismes mais en fait je
soupçonne de pâtes carbo en ville
attendent la guerre enfin en position
d'être pas mal en cinq minutes trois
minutes je pense je sais pas quel esprit
mobylette surface comme toi il à 26,46
en fait tu vas y dis pas bien mieux que
nous alors que dalle et ouvre les mac à
3000 quoi une raison et bouffon avec
cette année encore du déchet mais moi je
vais faire fuite n'y aurait pas eu du
coup mes amis 26 en fait c'est pas
beaucoup parce que c'est bien bah non
mais c'est vrai mon niveau de la merde
concrètement bayern inverse non mais
c'est à peu près le niveau en fait mais
de tuer on ne sont pas hyper à l'aise
ils se fondent et à tibi fourche
attendent d'être là et ce qu'on voit ça
à peu près notre niveau là pour dire que
pour des nuls qui dit mieux
sans rien faire d'extraordinaire il
devine bien son petit but inscrit
vié d'un peu mieux 27 60 c'est encore
dans l'arène des mecs que j'arrive enfin
tu as qui vont me battre mais qui me dit
ok il va me battre cède 3,8 deux mégères
c'est encore dans l'arène du des mecs
qui ne détruisent pas tu me réponds
mais parce que jardin roddis kim 29 de
10 06 n'ont pas encaissé ça dépend si
leur vie ou pas mais gère jusqu'à 27 50
28 t dans l'arène joues tu peux bon
piqué une partie par un têtu a perdu 8,2
en gros je pense mais en bullet 140
points c'est beaucoup d'écart non mais
ouais mais tu vois mvl il à 3000 et
kalil à 2900 et qu'elle coûte 3000 enfin
c'est c'est une énorme différence avec
les bords du haut niveau à ses quatre
ans à ses 300 points t'imagines bon là
pour le coup n'est pas trop mal mais m
vous voilà prêt c'est pas non c'est pas
je suis pas qu'il écrase on met des
opérateurs s'est pas trop mal passé
partir en week end
j'aurais bien voulu voir rick hansen à
leur place mais il s'est quand même fait
défoncer rick hansen dans la qualif
barton s'est pas qualifiée pour ça il a
joué les qualifs il avait le truc
préférentiels et il s'est fait éliminer
par ameur qui ça a pris fait détruire
par dominguez donc il était même déjà de
huit jours de classe quoi et il n'est
pas top élite mais plus de 2700 depuis
très longtemps et des champions du monde
2006 on l'avait déjà dit et fait c'était
une autre dimension en scène c'est très
bien c'est un jour à 2600 et lou quoi
mais c'est un mec qui débite sur
internet et qui joue vite et qui pas mal
enfin j'ai pas critiquer quoi ce jeu là
c'est mieux que moi même c'est pas plus
fort que ce qu'on est en train de voir
maintenant c'est clair non je vous mets
juste pour donner un petit exemple
enfin après met en scène rend plus forts
que nous mais jean russie pour les
arénas il avait perdu 3 0 contre contre
le joueur turc
ok après jean arthuis ce qui est pas mal
ou quoi mais les genres 27 50 25 50 et
il joue bien et où il est résistant mais
dire que tu peux voir que les plans des
vitrines
j'aime bien moi ce qu'il a fait non mais
pas de l'idée c'était kong et lettres en
f3 toulouse mb ça des 30 c 3 tout un
problème ça d'un proche cinq échecs tur
abdin il est toujours utile et très dur
mais je vais y réfléchir en fait avant
de faire mon je pense qu'il vit l'a pas
ratée l'idée est juste il va pas facile
et devant un truc mais je vais quand
même fait un choix sont fous
c'est toujours trop bien ces trois ans
toutes les cases au compte gouttes les
gagnants des trois fois entre moon et
keystone ya lieu trois quatre jeunes
feront tomber d'austin où il avait fait
le truc s'est impliqué très bien aussi
de repartir à l'attaqué quand le roi et
me laisser faire dame peut-être avec ton
stendhal naturel en fait le truc ce qui
m'a assez la tour du projet 3d mais je
trouve un truc
les gars là est plus fort clairement en
bullet in y fait le trou il fait le trou
ouais là il a ça y est il a fait le
trouve plus 3 y dominent le match il
reste quoi il reste quatorze minutes
décidé qu'on femmes non mais si ici on
vit ici on gagne c'est là il peut
peut-être fabuleux le match un peu
bizarre tu vois tu ce verrou 5
il faut pas agir la nef a bossé pour le
prochain procès entre guillemets
montrent un niveau ça peut faire cher
contre même socoa qui paye le plus fort
de voir un niveau comme ça tu prend cher
que le truc c'est que tu vas vite être
mené je sais pas mais on va dire 7,3 ou
8,2 et tu peux juste lâché match et
perdre marqué 5 points tu vas perdre 20
à 20 à 5 points pas tu peux tu peux être
pire ben oui et encore oui la chance que
je ne pouvais pas acquis juste sauvé de
la tête sous l'eau je pense contre nac
as tu peux prendre tu peux prendre très
cher
soyons pragmatiques n'est pas là pour
faire enfin un massacre oublié son match
il ya des nuls à feurs a fait un trou de
souris ils sont fous ouais mais après tu
avec le format ouais c'est ça mais tu
peux après toi auto crack est ma tante
était juste et bon là encore elle est là
la partie va faire laurent h un tour
deux terriblement pour la pratique non
alors ok varices et récupérer le pion à
mes grands lacs ont fait tour à deux 2
membres ou quoi faire d'autre
mais il s'est fait vraiment dominé dans
les ouvertures aux syriens faut dire que
tu as dit qu'ils étaient très bien
préparés tout ceci vous avez lâché
l'info direct des préparations c'est de
la merde ils n'arriveront où hélas grob
enfin tu m'as mes visites c'est quand
même avec sa bonne foi je pensais 6 et
évitait de peu vite mais bon ça ta
cabine tourner
je suis même sûr qu'il est bien non mais
ça se fête maman tu prends avec les
fixes à un torrent des 5 mm mais chaque
pour cette façon de présenter le mieux
est énormément ça c'est sûr mais des
videurs de graphismes c'est bien cette
rica et c6 quand même assez franche et
en un mécanisme ça sorte d'abri aux 4
c'est plus la même mais c'est jamais
facile dans le sang ces deux domaines
qui sont plus forts que nous et pourtant
on peut pas vous mentir et oui on a vu
un match exceptionnel ce soir c'était
c'est un peu le niveau zéro koidu du
speech est ce ça arrivait mais bon ça
permet de mettre en perspective le
niveau des grands champions aussi donc
c'est quelque part c'est utile voulu que
pas 1 5 pb 5
tu vois le tout à des fournisseurs ses
fusains et même là les échecs et les
machins dans les crocs
des quatre co fondé devrait habiter en
c3 fermer sa gueule
[Musique]
il va monter encore qu'est ce que c'est
bien joué de la part de visites tout en
contrôle après y'a peut-être répète pas
d'armes frondaisons deux patrouilles de
jeu à partir de 9 3 qui n'ont pas du
tout quoi même eu trois ça vaut le coup
cette cause cet ensemble enfilade
bon bah non mais enfin
non mais c'est ses rivales à l'heure du
match c'est très révélateur ans ferme
j'ai rarement vu un match de merde comme
ça vraiment on arrive c'est que j'aime
parler franchement femmes c'est un peu
la marque de fabrique de la chaîne aussi
tu vois ces deux pas de raconter
n'importe quoi aux gens qui écoutent
c'est pour ça qu'ils nous écoutent
jarque en rien un match de merde on le
digère point page et on va pas faut
arrêter quoi genre là ce soir c'est
enfin tu as même là c'est tout match
j'ai l'impression que pour aller jouer
encore une fois les deux meules et de me
battre et mais tu vois je pense pas que
je me ferais humilié là ce soir n'ont
presque pas surpris andrésiens aussi
faim jeu pour la plus de tout le monde
est abasourdi extra ou non mais l'art
est différent des trucs fous en train de
critiquer quoi qu'en fait les kids à 4,5
en l'air ça marche parce que le changer
si ce défaut de 15,5 me saute au bloc et
kf3 vous paye jean cressant d'un coup
les airs ça ils peuvent à faire enfin le
mec ce cas la grande attaque à ions de
1700 c'est choquant je suis choquée
femmes mais bon là en fait il sait qu'il
a perdu le match je sais pas non mais ça
a été ça tout le match ira au bout d'un
moment et puis c'est ce truc c'est que
c'est pas la première gaffe c'est sa
gt-r la faire ça après trois heures de
jeu qu'il était fatigué pourquoi pas non
mais c'est vrai que bizarre bizarre
bizarre mais ça les mecs dans le chat
ont eu raison après c'est vrai qu'en
bullet après enfin il a vraiment mon
niveau en fait vraiment c'est pas
choquant qu'il fait c'est-à-dire à ce
que je fais et elle sera finalement
c'est normal mais on a juste preuve du
dehors qu'on n'a juste pas l'habitude
est enfin moi je commence mes autos
parti et je m'élève tout le match en
disant je suis une merde parce que je
vois rien je suis tout le temps énervé
en fait quand je joue je ne comprends
pas comment on peut être aussi l'osé
chaque parent c'est ma réaction quand je
joue comme dirait vlad
quand on voit ton niveau on se demande
pourquoi tu arrêtes pas le cas massé
avait d'ailleurs déjà arrêté vers maman
plus vraiment quoi parce que je suis nul
du coup c'est choquant de parent n'a pas
l'habitude de commenter des mecs aussi
mauvais et fous des singles 3 f 3.5 la
première fois ça me paraissait assez
convaincant tout est changé mais
blizzard franchement moi je crois
quand on lit en là j'étais content de
voir un mec nouveau vote bref de torride
qu'il faut ouvrir le truc avec nouveau
vous voulez voir ça non mais peut-être
sur m
make nouveau ce que vantent si on me
dominguez en fait sur la qualif
d'abord été très bon non mais dur il est
passé par kalif jire si tu mets dans la
qualif le coup anglais mme landry qui
narre audit ce qui paraît je sais pas
des faits qui ont déjà bruins font
d'énormes qualifs et tous les mecs
j'étais si théo des bulls il veut le
faire il joue les qualifs là il a tué le
match
voulue dans le sous sol là je crois
qu'il vient d'élever le débat femmes
ouais bonjour tristesse
non non c'est le match j'entends déjà
rentrés trois noeuds ce moment-là nous
tiens non mais je pense à la chaîne
youtube ont montré sa statue connaît pas
non non tu es chat a été une culture web
quand même qu'il ya refaire vraiment
beige ocré du taureau c'est celle and
you tube
tout ce qui est game je suis je connais
rien en tête heureusement bonté la
trouve que ma culture
les illusions comme je t'ai envoyé la
vidéo de génie quand même c'est la s2
célestin quoi il faut que je regarde ça
les gêne y'a la vidéo à 28 secondes faut
qu'ils regardent y lâcher un petit coin
sous fantastique et le seul truc bien de
la vidéo en fait mais ce sera ça vaut le
coup en fait c'est il ya que ça qui veut
que dans la vidéo et moyens petit
souffle mais j'ai pas aimé qui vient le
cambrioleur il faisant croire que c'est
la police joue et en gros et difc la sg
rien quoi les gars je comprends que ce
n'est pas la police qui est juste celle
as pour lui et l'audio qu'est bonne
chance balle et on regarde et 5e aux
jeux non m ont attaqué et prend et je
peux attendre walkman à 1 912 5 points
d'avancé tu peux tu peux te lâcher
bakiev cinq niveaux à les envoyer quoi
fin il ya un truc qui avait pas sûr
qu'il ait fait ça je sais pas moi
j'étais pour envoyer de partout femme
n'est pas simple quand on prend des
saints étaient contents si tu me plante
payant des 600 médecins
questionné si si je dis que des
conneries ou 6 à sa résistance et 5 mai
mais ont réussi ce qu'elle fait une
connerie mais là lui il ya but aurait là
il va regarder henry s'il a mieux vu
convoqué en fin d'instruction
ok il à philippe bas c'est plutôt ce
niveau là qu'on entre autres à ce qu'on
attendait de la part de visites
ouais ce genre de truc en fait qui ne
voient tempo c'est ce à quoi on est
habitués on dit toujours en fait en
ajoutant un train de retard on est tous
dans la merde on commente on
l'impression d'être de conques ivoirien
quoi c'était pas le cas ce soir femmes
ouais c'est bien que toujours beaucoup
mon voyage quoi mais un jour il va faire
tout retour huitièmes il va tout
échanger sur rfi de faire voir pranger
si c'est nous peuples ont besoin
d'échanger l'atelier de louise t mais je
pense tu vois qu'un visite en forme il
aurait pu le ils auraient pu le jeu
beaucoup plus ils auraient pu le
décalque et je pense que le monde risque
de perdre son vrai niveau ça j'en sais
rien je connais pas bien qu'au jour
permet je pense que tu vois avec la
forme d'ambition maintenant un bis dit
normal ça peut ça peut finir il peut
finir à 4 points tu vois pas ce que les
deux premières au final qui gagne mon
mauvais début de match et on a une il a
clairement volé sur une arnaque chase
pourrait passer à sa pourrais 18 à 6 et
franchement en visite on a l'impression
qu'il a mal joué même s'il n'avait pas
raté ces trucs là tu vois nos meilleurs
de chaque partie
sarrazin n'affirme rien à ça a plutôt la
lèvre il veut décourager la tuer il a
perdu le 4è vêtements qui avait la dure
si je suis affûté ci soit ça tu penses
qu'il en mode célestin range ta chambre
jeu set et il est pas si mal finalement
ok ça va ça va ça va même bien on peut
avoir craqué quoi veux voir un petit
point bon ça relancera pas le match pour
autant mais juste pour pour lui pour lui
faire du bien stopper la série de deux
victoires d'affilée en séries lors des 7
je passe des trucs normaux comme ça
après faut quand même souligner qui se
sera pas écroulé sur sa chaise face ua
pour les trucs positifs
non mais j'essaye de tu vois les nuls de
vista mais c'est génial que les points
positifs d'une petite fille christian
bos et où c'est déjà bien que des années
j'ai de la peine pour lui
c'est à dire et à mes tours des noms
mais c'est la visite en fait il s'est
mis à jouer normalement entre
guillements après le fou tellement mal
en face que peut-être la fois f3 food
est oui mais non mais c'est vrai c'est
sûr liens vers des 5 es tu es tu as fait
un petit d'homme b3 des familles au mans
mais fait h5 que je trouve un peu chez
moi je dis assez facilement 5 7 pour pas
me prendre celui où on s'y met tous
pacifier un peu ton point si c'est
dommage pacifié avec a2a su avec un
s'est passé dans le sens passif pas
pacifiques ce qui est un peu les deux
ronds finale mais voilà voilà oui il y
surtout passif
je sais pas suffire wave 3 ou et tant
pis non mais non vous le tir amène son
radio de côté m le fond ces quatre et ça
va être fini quoi basse et tu veux faire
le fou n'est plus passif tous les quatre
ok mais peut-être en d5 lous camins
qu'on doit faire c'est 5 je préfère c4
picasso klee chier top à le groupe sion
que ce que c'est que ça tarde trop
proches comme quoi c'était la dernière
femme s'arrête là dessus le temps vient
de s'écouler
ok bon bah voilà c'était un grand match
on va pas se mentir
mes qualifs de visite bon bah de
compense un peu au dessus ils l'étaient
les moyens et prochain tour sera
plusieurs fois un forum de niveau vous
verrez bien là sa revanche de fond de
sauce et ça peut-être plus de chance on
a aimé ma souris je continue ses courses
au gris c'est parce qu'on a lu regardé
vite fait je vais
un truc facile mais je vais trouver le
truc t'inquiète comme ça on va dire aux
tontons un petit peu ce qui va se passer
pour les prochains matches a donc deux
matchs la semaine prochaine un fab de
belles rencontres surtout vendredi avec
j'ai envie de dire à un beau un baume à
mai geary ça c'est vraiment une belle
affiche franchement c'est mamie galli
d'accord c'est pas souvient attends je
sais pas non mais donc à part non là il
joue vraiment saut c'est sûr dans ce
tableau là donc oui il jouera contre sow
et oui et mais vendredi c'est cema
maigrir il fasse et numéro trois mondial
compte numéro 5 mondial sochaux est
passée contre eux qui en fait se serait
passé contre eux oui ah oui d'accord on
n'avait pas eu ce match que c'était
l'année où doivent être ceux et l'autre
partie de tableau va être très forte
qu'en fait le qualifie celui qui se
qualifie dans mame et guiry jouard au
déséquilibre est en fait les deux
tableaux en m&a prison fort et l'autre
chaise comme la fin tu as aimé
sur le papier ça va mais c'est juste
avec avec la forme du moment jaro il ya
deux ans tu te dis oui c'est
l'épouvantail bon là c'est en ch'ti pas
trop car mais rien en cause dans ses
qualités de gens à trensacq un saut
super joueur mais en ce moment sa
voiture il dit que normand du match
c'était mon clash sur nuisibles
franchement j'aurais devenue visible il
va rester quoi c'est pas apprécié pas
est ce que tu penses veut dire j'en
parle dans le live est ce que tu penses
que le enfin en fait j'ai posé une
question avant que vous êtes beaucoup
est ce que quand je mets des lives en
replay après vous avez une notification
pour dire qu'ils sont en couple et s'en
va être quand je fais mes trucs
d'exercice tu vois comme supposera une
heure avant de l'aider de faire ses live
ça fait super chic les gens ne doivent
pas de motif du coup je sais pas si je
le remets une deuxième fois tu vois et
vous recevez une notification je mets
des live tu as je pose une question
comme ça la communauté au passage
clavette sinon ça me saoule ojeda choix
de passer une heure et puis ça re fasse
pas une vidéo d'à une note yves parce
que pat a beaucoup de boulot derrière et
je trouve c'est pas mal quand même des
gens qui disent oui tant qu'ils disent
non mais dites vous vous pensez que je
remets je fais un micro montage et je
remets parce qu'en fait il ya des gens
qui l'ont déjà vu qu'ils vont se faire
spam une notice pour rien du coup je
sais pas comment faire
concert live de wii et pc ça en fait
bon je sais pas je verrai comment je
fais mais sinon vous en avait un qui est
que vous pouvez voir la même s'ils en
ont un machin dont je vais voir femmes
ne reçoivent pas les notifs une deuxième
fois en fait quand je les passants ont
répertorié tu vois les matches ce sont
les histoires je ne crois pas non ça sur
la chaîne chaise comme si si si lui
n'est pas sûr mais pas sur les cimes
ouais je peux reposte la vidéo en fait
je peux la supprimer et la reposte
c'était ce que je vais faire du coup bon
goûter les mecs à voir bon bah écoutez
on se on se retrouve bientôt prochaine
il ya deux autres matches m'a dit ouais
ben on était à 3 ratia mercredi ndlr
jeudi ses comptes komodo c'est pas un
speech a semé oui mais bon
ouais ce cas un très bon dans les
ferrari il ya en lui et pas les photos
c'est important mais il faut savoir dire
non mais c est vrai à prendre de speed
chaîne syfy voilà c'était ok bombay a
bientôt tout le monde quoi
à bientôt les tontons chao alors ouais
bail